foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody what's up it's
thanksgiving eve
yep it's gonna people are saying we have
a hope hope tom and jenny get [ __ ]
hella loaded tonight well what else is
new i do kind of feel like at least in
the united states i feel like in the
last few years it's sort of become the
custom to get shit-faced drunk on the
night before thanksgiving not for
everybody but i guess because so many
people are off work the next day and you
don't have to go anywhere so you can
just like sit around over and like eat
really fattening food the next day yeah
and just kind of slug around a little
bit
that's the video quality on this in case
we have another problem
yeah so we'll see you left your xbox on
that's why because it was it was kind of
like uh right so we should we should
have it in and out we should have a
solid connection i hope so like i said i
never like to say anything because it's
almost like it jinxes it yeah even
though i'm i'm not superstitious but
it does kind of like jinx it like
got um thanksgiving rolling along
did the cornbread last night yesterday
yeah whole house smelled like cornbread
yeah you made a whole bunch of that got
all that busted up to make stuff and
stuffing and dressing
got uh cranberry
sauce all made
um
got all
got all the damn
onions and celery prepped up and cut up
got my stockpot going with the gizzards
and the liver and the neck turkey necks
you know which times that yeah my dad
yeah that's a whole nother story
got that set up
got the turkey totally scrubbed down
inside and out with salt got it sitting
up
in the pot ready to go in it's in the
back refrigerator it'll go in in the
morning
it's ready to go but i gotta bring it
out stuff it gotta bring out stuff and
then it'll go you don't wanna you don't
wanna keep raw stuffing in there well no
no i'll bring it out tomorrow stuff it
if i can put the dressing around the
inside and put it in there
so i'll have to do it yeah
uh
put it in the oven just got two pies
baked
yeah
got two pecan pies baked
got the pumpkin pie but we bought that
um
yeah cause we used that pumpkin that we
had the other day make pumpkin bread
yeah which was delicious by the way some
of this [ __ ] you know what i mean it's
it's no sense in making one of them
because you have so much you can make
two
so you might as well just make the two
and one and why just make one what do
you get
[Laughter]
i got two other turkeys
but uh i was thinking for christmas and
in between
because it's so cheap up here right now
for that it's really weird i do kind of
feel like and like i said everybody's
different i'm not hating but um some
people are just kind of like
like danny rowland goes to i said i'm
having crab cakes instead of turkey for
thanksgiving this year just saying and i
do kind of feel like a lot of people
really don't
maybe not a lot of people but some
people really don't like turkeys they're
always kind of like they want to do some
other kind of fancy meal and i mean [ __ ]
man crab cakes there's nothing wrong
with that because i love crabs
but um
honestly i love
thanksgiving i love that i love turkey i
love mashed potatoes i like i love
stuffing i love pumpkin pie i love all
that [ __ ] i think if i ate it every day
yeah i would probably weigh a thousand
pounds one and two i'd probably get sick
of it
but
you know i
honestly like some people are like well
you know we make the thanksgiving thing
and then you have leftovers for like two
[ __ ] weeks or whatever
and
after a few days tom's always like man
i'm so sick of like turkey sandwiches
and stuff i'm like i'm not yeah she'll
eat it forever
i'll eat a turkey sandwich every goddamn
day i don't care i love it i totally
stripped that turkey of all meat by day
two that's i'll debone the entire thing
i'll have to back
all the little oysters what do you call
them the little soft spots off the dab
back i'll have all that stuff uh deboned
so it'll just have it i'll have a big
container sometimes i'll just have it
in a ziplock bags big heavy-duty
ziplocks just all the meat so you can
just reach in there and grab a handful
of damn meat put it in something
yeah
make some kind of thanksgiving is the
most british
of all the american
meals basically it's like a british meal
although turkey is not british we'll
sometimes have i bought a ham but i
don't know if i'll i don't think i'll
cook the ham this can be too much i'll
cook the ham later
that that that spiral cut ham was on
sale
um
so
yeah because some people like to have
both i mean at my mom's family we don't
they'd always have a turkey and a ham
you're right um whereas my dad's side of
the family you do turkey for
thanksgiving and at christmas you do a
ham yeah and like it is we didn't
usually do a turkey at christmas a lot
of a lot of what you're gonna cook it
depends on
one how many people you're cooking for
you know and whether or not you're
cooking in a group some families will
have three or four members of a family
chip in and make a big meal and then all
the relatives come over
just depends on the situation friends
can do that too one person doing it all
i mean
so you can do it we did it it's not that
expensive it's just that most families
don't i don't think what does this say
thank you tila hey tina's in the house
what's up t i guess she says fedex your
thanksgiving leftovers to me right it's
like i'm not gonna have it i'm gonna eat
them all but you know what i mean yeah
it wouldn't be good by the time it got
there i'd have to wrap it all up and
down
have to wrap it up and damn dried ice
yeah dartmouth said that uh that they'd
made um turkey curry one yeah we did
that one one year too i think last year
the year before yeah not for
thanksgiving but turkey no but like well
like after like after with that
turkey curry and and the main vegetable
in the turkey curry can be pumpkin we've
done that remember i mean
it wasn't curry though it wasn't chick
it wasn't turkey though i think it was
chicken it was chicken and
pumpkin curry but turkey would have
worked fine i think that was after
halloween it was after halloween yeah
yeah yeah yeah german said we have
turkey and ham for christmas in the uk a
lot of people here do as well
yeah like i said i guess it's the same
meal here thanksgiving and christmas is
real close i mean pretty much i think
there's more variation in christmas just
because
you know you're not restricted to turkey
yeah basically although like i said i
love turkey and it used to kind of make
me mad like
because my dad's side of the family like
i said they'd only do a ham that was
like their big thing at christmas like
sometimes people would bring other stuff
you know but like for sides
like ribs or meatballs or something but
it's just i was always kind of mad i was
like why can't we have another turkey
they're like which aren't you sick of
turkey we just had one for thanksgiving
i'm like yeah but the end of the year
end of the year turkey goes on sale
christmas tends to be actually tends
towards ham in the united states
but turkey's going to come up for sale
it's going to be 60 cents a pound 49
cents a pound i've seen it cheap like i
said nobody hardly anybody buys them the
rest of the year so it's like whoever
raises turkeys is always going to get
rid of they're trying to get rid of all
of them like for the holiday because
like i said most people don't think to
buy them the rest of the year and you
know
i don't know how it's going to be this
year but just past couple years
after thanksgiving like the day after
thanksgiving you'll find big ass [ __ ]
turkeys on sale 39 cents a pound 49
cents a pound
frozen people just walking by them and
i'm going
dude that's a six dollar turkey look at
the [ __ ] size of that thing seven
dollars for that [ __ ] turkey oh no
we're taking that yeah it's like we
could eat off that [ __ ] two weeks
yeah
and it's just because
it's going to go bad so they're just
pricing it to go
well yeah it's better it's
better for people to buy it another
thing i've learned here in florida is if
a hurricane's coming you wait for that
[ __ ] getting close wait for it to get
[ __ ] close all right
like
two days away a day away run down to
sam's and go buy up all that shrimp
because remember when we were getting
that shrimp big old [ __ ] that's right
bags of it for like four pounds of
shrimp
[ __ ] on
it was they were de-headed but they had
shells on them and they were the big
shrimps
so normally it'd be about twenty dollars
for a bag we're getting it for about six
dollars a bag yeah because like i said
they were like well our power's going to
go out because yeah everybody's thinking
the power is going to go out so it'll
all go bad
so the stores are just trying to get rid
of them and then people are afraid to
buy it because well if i lose power
it'll go bad and i'm like i got two
generators
give me the shrimp give me that give it
a try yeah that's right so i was
guarding another game shrimp guardian of
the shrimp
and then the power didn't go out anyway
that's true it didn't last no
we were eating shrimp boil
just for fun let's make a shrimp boil
just huge piles for the shrimp
man jenny with that damn
shrimp spice dripping down our [ __ ]
elbows
picking up corn pieces of potatoes big
old things of potato and all those
[ __ ] savages just yeah sometimes i
said [ __ ] it just shrimp
sit there and eat like two pounds of
shrimp meat per each one of those i said
shrimp it's very like boiled shrimp it's
very very easy to easily just like eat
your weight in that [ __ ] without even
really feeling all that full because
it's all protein i guess yeah it's all
protein it's super good for you
so in bodybuilders that are pescetarians
eat nothing but fish and shrimp and crab
you can build an amazing physique on
that if you're on the sauce [ __ ] yes
i mean honestly if i had to pick like
one kind of meat like a vague kind of
meat i'd probably pick seafood to be
honest it's my favorite um i'd be sad
that i couldn't have like turkey or
hamburgers or stuff but if somebody like
was going to kill me if i could only eat
one other kind of some people off those
islands are just sick shrimp can't they
just give it away for free at bars like
popcorn
well yeah i get that anywhere you know
well it's just kind of like people in
maine they're like look if i never see
another [ __ ] lobster jesus christ
it's like you know what i mean because
it's like everywhere but
i don't know i can see that but like i
said i don't
you know i don't get sick of
thanksgiving leftovers even after like
weeks and weeks i'm always just kind of
like man
i should be sick of like yummy turkey
sandwiches with stuffing on there and
some salt and pepper but i'm not you
know these nest is asking if i'm gonna
make sure ducting they're ducking
if you guys don't know what traductan is
because you get it down
first thing you want to get is you want
to get a cornish hand
and you slide that
inside of a
a turkey that's gonna be fly that inside
of a [ __ ] chicken and then you put
the chicken inside of a duck and then
you put the duck inside of the chicken
and then you [ __ ] deep fry it
yeah in a huge [ __ ] pot full of like
a peanut oil
with a burner underneath it outside you
don't want any anywhere near that [ __ ]
because it's going to be sitting on a
big stand and you do not want to be
anywhere around a [ __ ] big ass 10
gallon pot of [ __ ] peanut oil if
somebody spills it
yeah yeah that's like some [ __ ] out of
the medieval period yeah you will not be
able to get your pants and your boot off
fast enough the skin will come right off
with all your skin is going to come
right off
yeah not be a happy so you've got to
[ __ ] have experts getting that
[ __ ] turkey out of that [ __ ]
boiling ass [ __ ] pot
and you don't want any dogs or children
around they got you i can't be around
that's just [ __ ] risky
unless you're drunk when you're drunk it
becomes safe
something magically we're gonna share
that wow there's no problem
watch it i can do it i get to grab the
hook you want to put a pole and have a
hook in it a metal hook ready to go and
[ __ ] like you know a metal big-ass
metal fish hook with some wire around
its legs and then you [ __ ] get the
hook and then you put it up on a [ __ ]
grab it with a pole and put the pole on
a [ __ ] wooden bar and two guys lift
it up out of there and let all the
[ __ ]
juice drip out of it and lift it over
put it in a metal pan
that's the easiest way to do it
and then we're gonna like uh we're gonna
blow up a [ __ ] anvil in the air like
right next to the pot don't tell him
about that because we're drunk and yeah
it's called an anvil shoot
yes
sanders is laughing about the when your
trunk it becomes safe yeah actually
sandra we haven't seen you where the
[ __ ] you been uh her name now is sandra
knows it's hell being a sex symbol
oh yeah i remember where that came from
that's a long time ago
it's hell meaning
i gotta [ __ ] get in there with like a
gopro if i could take take fit and film
yeah you went yesterday didn't you yeah
yes there you go yeah get that was this
it was the sex symbol guy there being a
sex symbol yeah he was there he was at
the bar yeah he wasn't totally drunk yet
though
he was just head to high council there
the high council yeah
the high council are all the military
guys who are in their 70s they just sit
at a table and all confer with one
another and they're all wearing their
damn jackets and their hats and [ __ ] and
they got something they're super dude
come on over there now i'm busy inviting
me over to the high council table
[Laughter]
yeah i didn't have time for that though
you're too old you're like i got
drinking today
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] yeah well they're they're just
they're not bikers per se they're more
like golfers
you know like the guys that would walk
around at the va meetings with the
[ __ ]
walkers and their little [ __ ] jackets
and the hats and [ __ ] yeah the the vets
yeah
and they're a lot of them are officers
i'll talk with them but i don't really
hang out with them you know long term
you know
it's just you know they're just too old
you know sorry you guys are you guys
just too old
[Laughter]
tila says jenny when are you going to
make an appearance at the bar i don't
know maybe i will one of these days
music will drive you crazy it probably
will i got friends in low places that's
what you're gonna hear i know [ __ ] that
[ __ ] drive me [ __ ] like i said i grew
up around that [ __ ] and everywhere i
worked like played those radio stations
too so i'm kind of used to it
you gotta know if you go in there in the
evening it's gonna be [ __ ] country
all right i like to go there in the day
when uh you can go on the jukebox and
play rock
yeah because they'll play that too
you know but evening they're gonna put a
[ __ ] country in there well i'm not
going there in the evening yeah crap
well the sun went down so it was there
yeah that's right it goes down earlier
now well yeah
uh yeah sandra says first you changed
your time and i was always here at the
wrong time then we changed the time and
i was wrong again and then i was away
for a while
you know what happened this morning you
know how um when did we when did we put
the clocks back it's been a while right
like a week ago maybe or more
whenever we put the clocks back and i
thought that i got all the clocks most
of the clocks do it like automatically
obviously like the computers on the
phone and everything
but i could have sworn goddammit
that i had put back put back my little
digital clock that's on my bedside table
but
this morning i was like i looked at the
clock and i was like wow i slept till
like 9 30 or something like that i was
like wow that's pretty good um since i
was up half the night
uh but then when i came in my office i
was like wait it's only 8 30. what the
[ __ ] and then like i went i was like
checking i was like where are all these
wrong so i was like for a whole week
i've been getting up in the morning like
and thinking it's the wrong time and
like so i've been like having the wrong
time like all week what the [ __ ] camp
guys talking about knowing people making
pressure bombs yeah okay
he's trying to get me to tell stories
about anvil shoot it happens down in
mississippi on super bowl on super bowl
day
you'll hear these in certain areas just
hear these explosions all right and then
you might hear the cops
that depending on where you are the cops
go down there and they're looking for
where those explosions are coming from
they know what it is
in certain
villages of mississippi back in the 80s
90s this was the 80s late 80s when this
when from the story i'm telling you
about
they'd have these super bowl parties
out in these mississippi villages and
they used to do this thing called anvil
shoot
and this ship is [ __ ] dangerous all
right
you have you get you a big old
three-quarter inch steel plate about the
size of a manhole cover
or bigger
and you cut a hole in it using a torch
and then you weld some pipe on the
bottom of it okay
about six in six inches in diameter
and about a foot long and it's got to be
threaded
and then you
you you screw an end cap on it you weld
all that together so you got a plate
with a tube with an end cap and it's all
welded into one big solid thing you take
that you put that on in the back your
monster truck
and you take it out somewhere
dig a hole
and then drop that little tube into the
hole so you got a plate
sitting on the ground with that tube
going into the hole
and you take
some uh levels you know a little bubble
in there and you get that thing
perfectly [ __ ] level you're piling
dirt taking dirt away you want to get it
so it's so all those little bubbles
are perfectly in the center
and then you take
um one pound
of gunpowder or black powder and you
pour it
into that
tube on that plate
and then you take a bit of fuse that you
use from dynamite fuse or you can use a
model rocket igniter and a battery on
the end of a wire that's one way you
could do it
and you put that down in there with the
gunpowder
and then you and your friends grab a
anvil
and walk over to it gently
gently put that anvil down over that
[ __ ] hole with the gunpowder in it
run off run light the fuse and run
basically what you're gonna do all right
boom it blows that anvil way up into the
sky everybody sits there and watches it
all right and what you're trying to do
is get the anvil
to come down and hit the plate that
launched it so bing
and some guys will bet on it you know so
some guys won't
and you're doing this to to to
commemorate to make the inauguration of
the [ __ ] super bowl
that makes total sense makes total
[ __ ] sense in a way that it
completely does not it makes
sense
it'll get loud it gets so loud it'll
blow sometimes it's loud enough to
rattle windows or break a window so you
got to be careful about it but um
so we set off the anvil
boom and the apple goes up and there was
something about the way it launched it
went kind of sideways
and [ __ ] they forgot to shut the door
the dog saw it and started barking
barking at the damn anvil and sees it in
the air and it's coming down and they go
grab the dog grab the dog the dog is
running trying to catch the anvil and
jumps up into the air with its mouth as
the anvil is coming down misses the
anvil all right it misses the animal
thank you the anvil missed him and
landed into the ground made a damn
crater and the dog fell in the crater
that was the [ __ ] that was that was
that's my [ __ ]
you guys that's my [ __ ] handle shoes
so irresponsible we were going no no no
no no in the [ __ ] poor dog and you i
could see that dog [ __ ]
how would you have felt if that like
anvil like crushed that poor little
dog's head
when the little dog it was a hot dog
it's pretty big well the big dogs had
that what difference does it make it got
away they forgot to show they i would
have never been able to unsee that
i remember it [ __ ] that dog in the in
the air in slow motion with its teeth
coming up trying to grab that anvil i'm
going no [ __ ] all the hair stand up
on the back of my head but he missed it
and it [ __ ] when the dog
when a dog landed on the ground he was
still moving forward a little bit and
fell in the hole and then the thing
jumps up out of the hole like what was
that
newsflash no ideas
[Laughter]
dj maniac says uh ilsa landsdale and i
are working on a 13 o'clock podcast
drinking game apparently okay um yeah
and sandra says every time tom mentions
testosterone uh someone should drink uh
you would be dead in the first like half
an hour no no imagine that every time uh
every time he changes its subject
uh somebody says every time i laugh into
a glass or giggle into a glass also
maybe
uh sandra said something else i say all
the time i tend to say stuff like like i
said i say like i said a lot and you say
and stuff like that and stuff like that
yeah i say those kind of things too yeah
and stuff like that
so well yeah i notice it because like
when i record my videos yeah
sometimes i take it out but sometimes
like [ __ ] it that's just how i talk so
i'm just like not gonna worry about it
but uh yeah so and stuff like that yeah
i remember you know i remember
so yeah um i don't know it's i don't
know if i want to be responsible for
like
people dying of alcohol poisoning
from that but
oh yeah somebody says so you can still
use the advil for [ __ ] mechanical
purposes the anvil is almost totally
untouched it's totally untouched well
yeah yeah
you'd use it over and over again
the blast that sends it up into the air
the impact into the ground nothing
perfect
so it's not like you're
it's not like you're wasting the anvil
you got to get it out of the ground
though it takes a couple guys
it's it buries it it buries it a good
three feet
boom
dirt goes flying
it's like a bomb hit
kinda
if so it's like something fell into the
mud but it's not mud it's just regular
dirt
but under those amount of forces dirt
just kind of ripples like a damn water
you know
yeah
danny rolling ghostface says you guys
say know what i mean
more than earnest from the earth's film
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
and dj maniac says allegedly yeah
because i usually say that like
if i'm talking about something that
somebody said that i don't actually buy
so or that i don't think actually
happened i'll be like allegedly or if i
don't want to get in trouble
you know
we're drinking skye vodka
she's just drinking sky vodka and orange
juice mine's got uh matakuja which is in
english it's called passion fruit
with orange juice passion fruit orange
juice and vodka man that's good you see
he's fruity and passionate
germans don't know anything about
matakuja
also known as passion fruit you can look
that up sandra
that's that's the next one i showed you
i showed you peanut butter go check out
passion fruit
man that shit's good
i got addicted to when i was in brazil
and they they'll
they'll grind up a fresh passion fruit
and pour vodka in it man it's just good
that's basically what it is i got there
passion fruit sugar and vodka but i'm
not going to pour a bunch of sugar
instead i'll add a little bit of orange
juice which is sweet enough to kind of
act like [ __ ] [ __ ] they put passion
fruit and sugar yeah yeah [ __ ] me brazil
is all about i like sweet [ __ ] but man
that's that's a little much we had this
thing called a caipirinha all right
which was pinga
it's kind of like brazilian everclear
you throw a half a damn lemon and
brazilian lemons are green so
it's not quite a lime it's in between a
lemon and a lime you throw that in there
with the piga
or the cashasa
and then about
a third of a cup it's a shot of of pig
and then probably about almost a quarter
or one-third a cup of sugar over that
and then you grind it with a pestle
and
um what was the next thing they put in
there
that was it that was that was it i think
that maybe there's more panga
and it's called a kaipanian and it was
nothing but just sugar and ice sugar ice
and pinga
and lemon juice out of that thing
man that [ __ ] was [ __ ] strong if you
use vodka it's called a kaipet oscar
grind it's got the peel in it and
everything and you just kind of
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was insane
sandra said sandra said we do have
passion fruit you got passion even
sounds the same in german does it okay
yeah it's [ __ ] good
it's not popular in the united states
but it's real popular in central and
south america i mean you can get it here
you can get it nobody likes it it's not
like a real
i don't know it's okay i'm just like so
like i said it seems a little sweet for
me which is kind of why
i'm alarmed that they're like putting
sugar on top of it because like it's
already really sweet south africa
yeah south america we had a we had a
dessert called king jean
it's an indian word and it's like
custard it's really really [ __ ] sweet
it's got a layer
of coconut
and then like custard and it looks like
a little upside down cupcake
and then you pour carlos caro syrup on
it
it's spelled q-u-i-q-i-n
i put that in the cookbook q-i-n-d-i-n
yeah it's in a cookbook that's right
team dean
really good
but they're pretty small though right i
mean when you eat it you would just yeah
the size of cupcake yeah i could see
that yeah they're old-school brazilian
stuff
dj maniac says pinga is dick tom
what
[Laughter]
finga and portuguese means [ __ ] cut
they're talking about kashasa which is
like
it's like brazilian
everclear
closest thing would do would be air it's
sugar cane alcohol almost pure
and if it's like drinking
[ __ ] man all right that that hunter
proof
vodka i have back over there is mild
compared to pinga
[ __ ] you up
kinda like everclear but it tastes
different
you can run a car off of it
we used to
because the uh if that's what you're
into yeah
brazil had flex fuel and they had they
had uh volkswagen bugs that were
re-carbureted rejected
to run on
alcohol
sugarcane alcohol
the gas stations sometimes were closed
on sundays so you could get bingo or
cashasa for only a little bit more
expensive a little bit more than what
you bought it for out of the pump
you didn't want to drink that [ __ ] out
of the pump that wasn't stored in clear
contain good containers that would never
even have occurred to me tom dudes would
drink it dudes were drinking it i
wouldn't do it though
so what you do is you go to liquor store
and get you some cachaca pour that in a
tank
it
sometimes it'll be a little hard to
start but once it starts and the engine
warms up you could you can drive on that
so brazil had flex fuel back in the 70s
yeah way ahead of the [ __ ] [ __ ] way
ahead of the curve yeah but it was
because of corruption really more
anything else well you know
it's like anything else
what do you guys know
uh yeah the we're talking about vanilla
vodka madagascar vanilla with vodka and
orange juice no that'd be good yeah yeah
that would be good yeah
all right so are we ready to talk about
unless you have any shout outs we're
ready to go old west old west
that's we're talking about ghost stories
old west i know it's like it's not
really
because i tried to put like kind of
thanksgiving adjacent topics in the
patreon poll
um just kind of like american history
[ __ ]
and uh this one won by a long stretch so
i kind of feel like and i got like a lot
of comments when i put up the
thing earlier and a lot of people were
like oh i love old west [ __ ] and
everything like that so i mean the thing
about it is that there are so [ __ ]
many
ghost stories like old west ghost
stories like and legends and hauntings
and stuff
that
i really kind of had to just go there's
this really cool site i think it's
called legends of america.com or dot org
i can't remember
and they have like a [ __ ] ton
of old west ghost stories so i just
basically had to go through there
and
pick ones that i liked or that i that i
thought sounded interesting or were kind
of
well-known or whatever so we could like
kind of talk about them all right camp
guy is getting on me says tom it's not
called car road it's called k-ro syrup
in br in portuguese there's no a it's an
ah so they call it caro
cabral syrup
sorry
we have it here but i don't you know
it's
what do you make it make [ __ ] pecan
pies with it
there's not much you can make candy with
it that's about it but yeah i remember
buying it when i was a kid to make candy
yes you'd make like hard candy yeah but
if you're going to make king jean
they're going to say give me some alcaro
cabro syrup yeah so
i'm teaching you some [ __ ] some style
man this is some culture
give me some culture
okay you ready to do it tom's giving me
some culture i'm giving when i'm giving
you culture something's wrong probably
it's bad
yeah i'd agree with that there's another
t-shirt guy we have so many
stylish stylish and cultured are two
different things
all depends on your point of view it all
depends well that's true of most things
sandra says pookie is crazy about your
treats ilsa that's absolutely true
they're gone now but she just finally
like finished all the box except she ate
them all up yeah uh in almost all the
shows i saw lately she started digging
for them yeah because i had the boxes
over there and so if i did because i'd
put some out for like on the little dish
yeah but if it got empty she'd be like
hey you [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and she'd
start like scraping on the box i didn't
think cats had the intelligence to plan
ahead or really didn't no they can
she has all these little dishes and all
these little boxes around she knows what
color is what what flavor comes out of
what color she'll go right up to want a
box of what she wants it goes boom boom
this one yeah because we usually have
like a few
right
next to each other and if a bowl starts
getting low she's got a couple little
bowls around here she she wants
different flavors in each bowl at all
times and if a bowl gets low she'll sit
there and go look look
like point with her little nose
that's getting low
and then you give her some and she goes
thank you and walks away she's not
hungry she's planning ahead yeah and
she's like i feel like i'm gonna want
that flavor later right so so because
she knows it's getting late we're gonna
be asleep yeah so
no they're they're a lot more they're a
lot smarter than i thought they were
they're a lot smarter than they told me
they were when i was a kid
we've advanced
since then
animals are much more aware of what's
going on than what i believe them to be
pookie's super smart i think yeah
when i was a kid and i was hunting i
thought certain animals were mean and
they weren't mean like i used to think
raccoons were mean no raccoons aren't
very mean no you scare one they can get
mean but they're not very mean
it's a lot of stuff has changed we
didn't think you could keep certain
things as a pet like big cats
man there's all kinds of people keeping
big cats as pets make a good pet my
online make a great pet
it's just we weren't educated to know
that
there's limits though that's a big cat
yeah you know
well even a house cat will [ __ ] you up
yeah
beige put me in the hospital it was
that's right she didn't mean to right
yeah she wasn't being mean she just
panicked you gotta understand a person
will kill you your child will kill you
yeah you know [ __ ] like that has
happened
you just can't really live in paranoia i
don't let fear control me you just yeah
this [ __ ] could hurt you but it's not
hurting me now so it'd be all right yeah
it's all right right yeah sandra says
cats can totally plan ahead and also
remember things for a long time yeah and
they can think logically yeah any
studies on that yeah they think very
well and and remember you and they also
are really good about knowing what your
emotions are they're they they read body
language very well
yeah that's absolutely true
danny rolling ghostface says not too
long ago there was some guy on youtube
talking about a haunted wild west town
that was offering to pay someone to be a
caretaker of that town but plot twist it
was haunted i think i remember hearing
about that actually i sense [ __ ]
well there's so many like ghost towns
out there like i said this was kind of
like
i just sort of thought of this topic at
the last moment like when i was putting
the patreon poll up and i was kind of
like oh that might be kind of neat
because you like old west [ __ ] and it's
like and there's so many ghost stories
and everybody likes the ghost stories i
just realized that we've done like
paranormal stuff like all this month
because that's what always gets uh what
always gets voted for
but
i don't know and like i said it's not
really anything to do with thanksgiving
necessarily but it is to do with like
american history so yeah nowadays
everything's haunted
yeah you can rent it
well yeah i mean it's just in a lot of
ways it's just like kind of a marketing
it's a marketing thing floy i mean well
you know
we got a ghost town it's haunted do we
need a caretaker
there's more to that story they they
want people to come through there or
something
it is a good way of you know if you have
kind of a bed and breakfast or something
like that that's not doing too well
right
if you kind of like spread around a
rumor that some horrible
crime happened there back in the old
days right trying to kick up interest in
the place oh it went red oh okay we're
back back okay yeah oh it went right
again please don't tell me you went
green it's back okay it's crazy it's
just i'm hoping that this is not gonna
be doing this all night because look
people if it
nods out give it a few minutes
i usually like i said as soon as it goes
red i usually try to stop talking yeah
you know what i mean but it usually
comes back if it doesn't come back we'll
open up another stream yeah
after i'd swear a lot right
because [ __ ] should just work god damn
it and i don't understand why it doesn't
uh so yeah so
uh tom knows some old west [ __ ] so like
i said just kind of feel free to
i just picked out these are pretty much
at random or just ones that i picked out
because i thought they sounded
interesting
um or had to do with people that were
kind of famous or well-known or whatever
so
if i didn't include your favorite one uh
i apologize for that but i just kind of
had a smattering of different ones
so let's talk about the jesse james farm
and this is in kearny
missouri
so this is the house where both jesse
james and frank james were raised
uh their mom
whose name was zerelda
uh she was uh married to three different
husbands presumably not at the same time
because that would uh be something
uh and she ended up having eight kids
now
this house in particular was where
jesse james's brother one of his
brothers archie
he got murdered by the pinkertons
uh in this attack where she also ended
up losing a hand so that's kind of
hardcore let me tell what the
pancreatins are or is that going to be
in there uh no you can go ahead
the penkertons were kind of like the
boba fetts of the old west
they were mercenaries they were
contracted
um the pinkertons also
were the very first secret service and
bodyguards to the presidents
so this whole weird thing about
corporations merging with the state
and the state hiring
mercenary corporations to fight wars and
to do things even inside the united
states that's been going on from the
since the very very [ __ ] beginning
pretty much
the pinkertons were the first
professional detective agency
made up of law men and criminals they
hired talent where it was wherever the
talent was
that's where they hired and this
included very talented ladies of the
evening they hired them to train them as
spies because even back then they knew
that
if some chick was shaking out some [ __ ]
for a dude
in moments of weakness he'll tell her
everything he knows
been going on forever so professional
girlfriends
they were into that women make good
spies women
sophie is going like she loves combat
[ __ ] she's into women in the military
type deal and she's [ __ ]
not real happy with
the performance of shit's going on with
women in the military and i said so
a woman's strength if you're going to go
by genes and genetics and female
abilities
the women's biggest combat strength is
to be a spy
that's really where that you know they
prey on the weaknesses of men
[ __ ] got loose lips
and uh yeah
a single female spy
in the right [ __ ] position around the
right guy you can win an entire war or
an entire battle
spies female spies
james bond nah madam curry more like
that
or better madame curie she was a
scientist yeah yeah no okay what's the
other one madam curry the other one was
i was thinking about it
that's a totally different
heart mata like she invented like she
was discovering radium yeah that's right
i was thinking about heart
[Laughter]
close
not really but okay you know a funny
name
i been drinking
yeah she is more she was more [ __ ]
valuable than the well for a second i
was like wait was madame curious bye i
don't know i don't know about that
is [ __ ] she is more valuable than any
[ __ ] battlefield soldier
yeah
and uh
they [ __ ] showed up in weird places
like some of these [ __ ] dead women in
hotels with guns somewhere in europe and
we don't know who this is and no tags on
our clothes we've done shows on them
east german sex operatives that's what
that is spy well they're pretty sure
that that's what is doll woman was his
daughter one that she was probably a spy
yeah because she had all kind of wigs
and different passports and
[ __ ] like that yeah an itinerary that
was coded they recruited from brothels
usually
bravo's in prisons or a mixture of the
two
but uh no they can turn them into
[ __ ] badass [ __ ] agents
all right that's it elsa says i'd love
to be a spy yeah uh it also says where
is sophie anyway
so he's doing she's she's at home yeah
she yeah she's doing government contract
work right now [ __ ] with the post
office
but she doesn't know how this is going
to go she actually wants to come for a
visit but she has to see what's going on
with it with the next contract that
opens up
she wants to come to florida
saunders says who knows madame curie's
secret life is a spy that's exactly what
i thought because i was like oh i meant
my i smell a short story these [ __ ]
make one mistake he's busy won't driving
in the ground
oh i'll do it okay no i'm just saying
that that would be a good though that
that would be a good short story well
sometimes when you misspeak or you say
crazy [ __ ] like that it kind of like
yeah it puts together things in my head
that i'm like oh yeah
well here's the thing
a lot of [ __ ] spies were also
scientists a lot of scientists were also
spies or dual operatives
especially uh
back in the cold war
scientists that were involved in the
nuclear bomb projects and [ __ ]
nuclear stuff
at that particular place in time
a nuclear science science scientist was
his knowledge was worth a lot and the
soviet union is worth to pay with the
soviet union was [ __ ] willing to pay
a lot of money to know what he would
know so some of them were
playing both sides although i mean
that's understandable but i think some
of that i think that's still
i think that's still officially
classified but
most people believe that i think his
name was uh oppenheimer
i think his name was oppenheimer
uh
most people believe that he was a double
agent that he was double dealing
although that was never declassified but
the rumors were he was selling
selling information to the soviets well
like i said knowledge is valuable and if
you are the kind of person that has
knowledge that a lot of people don't
have
then you know i can understand it would
be very intense they just needed numbers
theorem and [ __ ] like that yeah that's
that's what the soviets needed
um all right so
we're going back to the back to yeah
talk about pancreatitis well yeah you
talked about the things
so we just said yeah the pinkerton has
attacked this house and killed jesse
james's uh brother archie and also uh
shot or shot off i guess shot off or cut
off uh the mom's hand
now jesse james uh was killed not at
that house though which i don't think he
was killed at that house um but after he
was killed he was actually his body was
brought there and buried at that house
because his mom was still alive
and she wanted to be able to like guard
his body against people that would like
dig it up or souvenir hunters or
whatever which they did back then yeah
so because people were gross
that's worth big money out well yeah
back east you could sell that [ __ ] yeah
dime store novel heroes
yeah and like i said i think we even did
we even ever talk about that one where
that one that uh that urban legend that
turned out to be true about the
the kind of skeleton that was hanging in
the fun house that was in line wasn't it
yeah yeah and that turned out it was a
real yeah that was a real body and it
had been in there for like decades it
looked wrong when i saw it as a kid i
was like that looks real yeah they're
like wow that's some good special
effects yeah it was it was a mummified
fight [ __ ] dude and it was from the
old west right well old west era it was
like a criminal or something yeah and
then just his poor body got like carted
around all the different [ __ ] yeah
that's great
the rumor was when it happened when they
discovered it
back in the 70s when i was a kid when it
finally came out that was real my mom
was like i knew that was real and i was
thinking of myself as a little kid
because she was next to me i was like
yeah that was real
um
they said that it was uh that it was the
mafia put him up in there that was
somebody the mafia had killed that's
what the rumor on the street was this is
pre-internet yeah so people just made
[ __ ] up
that was uh because that wasn't actually
the first fun house he'd been in yeah
the body had actually been sold with a
bunch of other props right like around
different fun houses like he was a legal
body he was not an illegal body yeah
yeah he knew it was real yeah but it was
just like a body you could buy like
buying a mummy which you can own an
egyptian money you can own an egyptian
mommy well a lot of people did a lot of
people do yeah [ __ ] man well back in the
old days they found they were finding so
many mummies that they were like
grinding them up and
selling for powders drinking drinking
them yeah crazy which
uh they were using mummys toys
okay yeah they're like look we just got
mommy's like you just walk a [ __ ]
foot and you'll trip over a mummy
they're everywhere to be fair though
they weren't anxious egyptian mommies
yeah not really i mean to be different
it's just ones yeah these were like
minor mummies they were mommies they
were mommies from the time when uh
when egypt was it was a greco-roman
possession
and
it was a long time after the pyramids
but local egyptians had themselves kind
of tarred dried and they tore them up
and buried them and they were selling
that [ __ ] back in europe all through
[ __ ] centuries look an ancient
egyptian no not really kind of more like
a roman from a [ __ ] couple hundred
years ago
well still it's a mummy yeah
but they were using those things to
power [ __ ] steam engines because they
burned for a long time they weigh much
yeah
people are funny man
it is very funny it's really weird when
you think about it like that i don't
know very strange but yeah so uh so yeah
so he was buried there for a while he's
not buried there anymore obviously
because they moved his body later on
but i guess because of all of the [ __ ]
that happened uh over the time obviously
the jesse james farm is said to be
haunted said to be haunted more than a
century
um so what people have reported
is uh the biggest thing is people see
lights moving around inside the building
and outside
uh where there's nobody in there it's a
museum now i think but you know so you
can actually still go visit there
um a lot of people have also reported
hearing like hoof beats like outside
like a whole bunch of horses
uh muffled shots
and kind of like just something that
sounds like a battle or something that
sounds like
you know people shooting into the house
and people screaming and [ __ ] like that
um also uh yeah so there's lights inside
the building after it's locked um
there's kind of like stuff seems to move
around
um in the
inside the house but it doesn't come up
on the monitors like you know what i
mean they have like motion cameras yeah
and the motion cameras will be triggered
by movement but it's like you know
they'll be triggered but nothing's
moving you know what i mean like the
camera will move but it doesn't like
show anything
um also like i said people kind of hear
sort of like voices outside and horses
like in the woods around it but then
when they go check there's nobody there
um [ __ ] like that so again that's kind
of like uh one that's sort of famous
now let's talk a little bit about
[ __ ] creek colorado so that's it on
the jessie yeah yeah yeah like i said i
have like a [ __ ] ton of different ones
some of them are long and some of them
are short okay um and some of them kind
of have more of the history behind it
and some of them don't it's just
dependent there's not much to say about
jesse james until somebody goes down
there and investigates it
yeah um
i tend to think when it's hauntings
around famous people i tend to believe
[ __ ] probably not
yeah because i i really do feel like
even in the ghost world
yeah uh celebrity matters yeah
[Laughter]
you're trying to sell [ __ ] nobody wants
their ghosts to be
be some schlub yeah the chances of a
[ __ ] paranormal event and a celebrity
happening at the same time are very
unlikely
i've seen paranormal [ __ ]
the celebrities weren't involved chances
are how do you know it's all very rare
and usually if something paranormal
happens a celebrity will not be involved
even though they had a whole
series on them back when they had
television about celebrity ghost stories
that shit's still on you know that's a
lot yeah i don't even think tv still
exists yeah it does i mean who's
watching that i don't know not me but
apparently some people are ridiculous
well yeah because
i heard they got gumball machines too
ain't that something
although they haven't been all those
dead malls and i'm just kind of like
well i would never get any gumballs out
of there because who knows how the [ __ ]
long they've been gumball but she's
probably full of spiders in years
to me television programs are like
gumball machines that's something that
should no longer exist
i'm pretty sure celebrity ghost stories
are still on there probably in its 40
bajillionth season much like ghost
adventures yeah
all television is a ghost event it's all
[ __ ] paranormal i feel like
everything is ghost stories it's all
good
which i don't have a problem with that i
mean animals entertaining the animals
[ __ ] planet was nothing but ghost
stories
haunted dolphin
hoffen haunted dolphin planet not gonna
lie
by the way a dolphin saw this haunting
and then it goes back to the haunted see
they used to crack me up i don't even
remember what the name of that show was
well animal planet yeah that's where i
don't know i don't know if animal planet
still has like actual animal content
like because jackson galaxy was on there
and stuff like that but they did have
one paranormal show i don't know about
now this was years ago that and i can't
remember what it was called it didn't
have anything to do with pet ghost
nothing like that yeah but it was always
it and i thought when i first saw that
it was coming on there
i was kind of like oh are they gonna
talk about
people that have seen ghosts of their
pets yeah like my dog died and then like
i kept seeing the dog or hearing the dog
or whatever no it's just a regular ass
haunting yeah but somehow the cat saw it
yeah right it's like it's very shoehorn
because of the licensing agreement
because of the licensing agreements of
the damn channel
you have to mention an animal in every
[ __ ] episode
they're like yeah mr waffles got really
really upset one day when i heard a
funny noise in the attic right like the
extent that was the last time you hear
about it
well you think they'd do some [ __ ] like
that
with the dolphins
the big old haunting story oh and by the
way there was a picture on the wall
and in that picture was a man holding
another picture of a dolphin
[Laughter]
yeah
i would um i'm not gonna lie i would
watch a show called haunted dolphins
yeah haunted dolphins
that gives me another idea for a short
story you got a really dumb one it's
yeah you got a
wedge of dolphin into the story somehow
yeah the ghost and i saw the ghost and
that [ __ ] i was walking by to what
were you wearing today i was wearing
this t-shirt jeans and [ __ ] tennis
shoes what was on your t-shirt picture
of a dolphin miami dog
okay there you go
we're gonna have a whole episode that's
animal it's animal content yeah yeah
yeah
dolphin haunting
[Laughter]
yeah episode seven
oh my god
haunted dolphin phantom flipper yeah
yeah yeah phantom flipper
[Laughter]
oh dj maniac
wedge a dolphin in my ass by chuck
tingle yeah
has he written one called that he should
he should have
i don't know if his dolphins really is i
feel like dinosaurs are more his thing
but uh it could be i don't know if he's
dead the worst one of all times if you
ask me the worst one of all times the
one that this it's basically what i said
[ __ ] it and i i gave up television
was when when i saw that they had a
program called killing bigfoot
and the rednecks jumping up up out of
the ground
before they have like every episode with
a shotgun and it was caught yeah
with lights i heard something
yeah and it's just fake rednecks and
[ __ ] you know dressed up as
hillbillies yeah just like the ducks we
gonna kill bigfoot and i was just like
uh that's it i turned off television
never [ __ ] turned it back on that was
it it should have been called television
killing bigfoot with an asterisk right
and then asterisk rednecks do not
actually kill bigfoot
and really
killing bigfoot was a response
to
the same kind of
[ __ ] ethnic games but in another
direction even though it was a good one
it was called ghost brothers
ghost brothers was good it was black
dudes on ghost hunts
it was pretty good though it was [ __ ]
funny well they were well i i liked that
show because the three guys they were
funny and like they like their
interactions were funny like making them
[ __ ] stay in the room they were funny
guys
making them they weren't douchey like
the ghost adventures but they saw that
and that that was a success and they go
well [ __ ] we gotta have rednecks we're
gonna call killing
and i was like that's it i turned that
[ __ ] off okay i don't even know if ghost
brother is still on that was a long time
ago that was a good like i don't even i
didn't give a [ __ ] about the ghost stuff
just those guys
those dudes were just entertaining they
were funny
because they were taking it seriously
but not exactly
you know what i mean i don't know they
were just funny they were just trying to
try to like look man you stay here all
right we're gonna turn the lights off
all right you stand here and see how
long you see if you can stand here
[ __ ] 30 minutes it's like all right
all right you say you're scared and i'm
scared
put the flash right we're on here we'll
have the camera right there it'll be all
right just 30 minutes okay man and he's
like oh man
this [ __ ] sucks
well i think that's kind of what i like
about
the buzzfeed unsolved ones like i
usually like the true crime ones i don't
think they do those anymore but uh they
still do the paranormal ones
and actually they did one about
tombstone arizona which i'm gonna be
talking about later
uh where they went to all these
different places
and that's a good show because one the
two guys are like best friends and like
their
their back and forth is like really
funny and also because ryan
is believes in ghosts and he's like a
total wuss about it like he's really
scared of them and the other guy shane
just totally does not believe at all and
is also always like busting his balls
about how he's like scared about it and
he's it's just so so funny like their
interaction is very very funny uh sondra
asked if anybody had seen the new
ghostbusters movie i haven't seen it it
kind of looks good from the trailer is
it out yeah it came it started last week
or the week before we can go see it
we'll go see i think oliver harper put
up a
review for it but like a non-spoiler one
but i haven't watched it because like i
said i don't usually like to watch
reviews beforehand
but you know i don't know it's like i
said the trailer look good i don't know
if it's i said like i said again oops no
i just said it a third time yeah you
guys are gonna be so drunk by the end of
this
just don't listen to me all right so
we're talking about [ __ ] creek
colorado
uh specifically the imperial hotel
now back in 1896 there was big ass fire
that destroyed most of the city this
kind of happened a lot out in the old
west what are you guys like building
your [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
matches and oily rags
that's what happens and you light
everything with lanterns and everybody's
drunk all the time and they're just
knocking lanterns over and whoops burn
that whole town down again because i
just feel like every town in the old
west
burned completely to the ground at some
point it's just i don't know every
single one has that so [ __ ] creek
colorado no exception
uh so uh they have wood they didn't have
fire that's what i'm saying that's what
i'm saying and they were drinking all
the time that's what i just yes
that's what i just said yeah
uh that it wasn't a good combination
[Laughter]
yeah so oh yeah big barrels of gunpowder
you know
uh so after that fire there was this uh
they built the imperial hotel
because there were a bunch of like
miners and you know various people
coming to the area
now uh when it was first opened it was
actually called the collins hotel and it
was kind of fancy like they had uh
electric lights ooh
they had steam like a heating system all
that stuff
so
the original owner the or the manager i
guess like the guy that ran the hotel
back in the day
was a dude named george long he was
originally from england
and uh he was married to his first
cousin which i guess a lot of people did
back then
so him and his wife ran the hotel
and they also had three kids now their
oldest daughter alice
maybe because of the inbreeding i'm not
sure first cousins i get i don't know it
depends on how closely genetically
related they are but their oldest
daughter
was supposedly
not right like she was kind of mentally
um
mental problems and they said first
cousins as long as it isn't generational
in other words first cousins over many
generations so you can get away with it
yeah it's well like i said it kind of
depends on
i don't know it depends on how you have
a population that continuously marries
first cousins over time that [ __ ] you
out little yeah but
every once in a while
i mean
yeah
because that's because they were
there's certain communities that still
do it in certain parts of the world they
have [ __ ] bad birth defects
i talked about it we had one in the old
community where that old place we left
places in the middle east that do it
and the
boy's head was swelled up
his sister remember we saw her sister
she looked kind of [ __ ] up that's
because
it's over in pakistan [ __ ] in certain
parts of them certain tribes will
because it's tribal they'll marry
cousins over and over and over and over
again i'm just it's preferred
dang to marry your cousin
sandra strangely enough saundra back in
the day it was like that in germany as i
understand [ __ ] old mustache man and
his [ __ ] first and his first cousin
had a thing going galley well her name
was gaily she she shot herself and
killed herself over a mustache man
but evidently
over him or because she was sick of it
over him no okay no
people [ __ ] don't realize before
mustache man had a bad reputation he was
very popular the women liked him
um
he wore funny clothes and uh
made speeches and what a funny little
mustache man you wear yeah well he he's
trying to copy [ __ ] uh charlie
chaplin actually which that's not a joke
yeah i know and um
you know he was a goth kid of his time
artist and [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not claiming
him sorry
when you when you see you know you're
going to the opera they were all weirdos
that's the thing about [ __ ] those
guys
they were weirdos yeah they were weirdos
they were sam the eagle there in case
they were into free love and running
around nudism and [ __ ] uh
pansexuality uh that you know that
that's what that was
but you know sorry but
that's what they were
it just got weird as that [ __ ] went on
yeah it got a little it got very weird
identity politics man [ __ ] leads you
down bad paths don't do it
saunder says jenny they built everything
out of wood and drank a lot yeah it's
because everything was made of wood and
they were always drunk well i told you
he doesn't listen to me when i said i
was listening to that he always liked
backing her up i've been drinking he
repeats everything i say like a minute
later
elsa says you can share up to a quarter
of your dna and still be okay yeah
that's roughly what first cousins are
yeah like i said i think it's more of a
thing where if you just keep doing it
over and over and then sandra says
legally you can still marry your cousins
here i don't think anyone does but you
are allowed to honestly i think half the
state's here you can yeah i i'm not
please correct me if i'm wrong it's not
like i've ever looked into this but i'm
pretty sure that florida you can yeah um
but as i i don't know anybody that has
ever done that last i last i heard
the state of mississippi age of consent
is 14.
ain't that something ageless consent is
14. yeah now they think they might have
statutory clauses where you can't be but
a certain amount of ages over years
older than which that makes sense that
may be there but that's a new law
it used to be
you could marry a girl at 13 as long as
the parents consent to it and i don't
think [ __ ] age was of the hutt of the
husband
was ever mentioned
but that's old very old but hell yeah
they're still in the face jerry lee
lewis married his 13 year old cousin
so oh if in the south in those days no
problem yeah no problem and he was 26.
no problem
maybe older there would have been no
problem in the old south
that would have been although when he
went over to europe they were kind of
like yeah like what
in the old south not happening in the
old south that would be considered
quaint
that just the cultural context is not
the same
i know it's crazy like yeah you're
taking care of a young and helpless
person that's good that's good and she's
your family too that's good keep you
know the keep the clan together that's
the way they
where
it's like then pakistan same thing but
they just do it over and over and over
again you can't do it over and over
again yeah you're going to have a bad
time all right danny rolling ghostface
says i saw a ghostbusters afterlife it
was good okay it looked like i said it
looked good i said like i said again see
i keep doing it i'm trying not to do it
and i guess trying not to do it is gonna
make me do it more so i should just stop
worrying about it what's up pokey pants
oh hi pookie
so yeah we got we got off on the first
thing
so their oldest daughter alice as i
mentioned
uh had some kind of severe mental
disorder not really sure what it was
but uh it got to a point where when she
was you know as she aged
she was starting to get so
uh misbehaving i guess
that they had to
keep her locked and they had an
apartment next to the lobby because they
you know worked in the hotel and ran it
so they had to keep her locked in there
which you know seems a little cruel but
you know
now
today this is where the red rooster bar
is now a little while after this
suspiciously or maybe not so
suspiciously george
was walking down the stairs to the
basement and
fell
and died
now
whether it might have been an accident
it could it happens people fall
downstairs all the time and die
but the legend went around that alice
the daughter
had gotten out of her room and like
pushed him down the stairs
uh or like hit him in the head with a
cast iron skillet and then he went
flying down the stairs no one could
prove that allegedly um but that was the
story that went around
now in 1948 uh they also opened this
thing called the gold bar theater and
then they had this so they had like all
these actors come in
and
they that went on for a really long time
i don't know if it's still going on
because this i'm pretty sure this hotel
is still open
nowadays
but uh for a time they had the longest
running theater in the nation
uh and they also added a casino in 1992
so they changed their name to the
imperial casino hotel
now the ghost that this supposedly has
the most common one is george long the
guy who fell down the stairs or
was pushed or hit in the head with the
pan and fell down the stairs like by his
daughter
one thing that george long likes to do
this is what it said on the legend of
america page the ghost of george long
likes to flirt with the ladies i'm not
sure in ghost form what that would
entail
um
also he likes to play the slot machines
more understandable
what would ghost flirting entail
i don't know
now i'm cut now i'm curious there's
another idea for a short story ghost
flirting ghost flirting
i kind of feel like maybe flirting isn't
the word maybe it's like maybe it's more
like ghost sexual harassment where
they're kind of like just grabbing
people's ass maybe that's what they're
talking about
which is not flirting
back in those days it would have been
it's like who just who just pinched my
titty yeah
it's like invisible hands going hong
kong they were more forward back then
they had they had a more they were more
permissive with their sense of humor
oh my god slapping [ __ ] on the back
of the ass when they walk by like bonds
used to do and [ __ ]
yeah that's bond that wouldn't fly
nowadays nowadays you turn around that
woman will punch you right in the mouth
depends on whether she likes you or not
though well like if she doesn't know you
she will absolutely turn around and
punch you in the back you snap a [ __ ]
on the ass like that and [ __ ] she's
gonna call the cops on you now yeah i
wouldn't punch your [ __ ] teeth down
you throw you do that kind of [ __ ] to me
holy crap but uh yeah
so apparently what happens is they'll
close down the casino part of the hotel
and everything's closed nobody's in
there and they'll start here in the slot
machines and they'll start hearing coins
like falling into the bottom of the slot
machines
but then when they go in there to check
on it there's no coins in there and none
of the machines are on psych so they
think that the ghost is in their place i
don't know again i don't know what the
ghost would be doing with the money in
the afterlife
no it's teasing you
he's like i gotta win some money to buy
some like ghost chocolate bars i don't
know jose doesn't know it's in the
afterlife i guess maybe not he's like
i'm just still gonna hang around in this
casino man this is really nice
yeah and uh yeah so there's that whole
thing going on
and then there's also a thing where a
lot of guests pro primarily female
guests
have said that um
they've felt somebody in their room like
touching them i don't know if that means
like just touching like touch or if it
means like
again like sexual harassment touching
again
this ghost seems a little handsy
uh
not sure i'm okay with it and um
apparently one of the maids that worked
there also reported having her butt
pinched so again
i think their definition of flirting in
my definition of flirting are two very
very different things i'm just saying
another thing that's been reported is in
the theater part of the hotel
um some of the actors that are still in
there or were at least as of this
writing like when this uh when this
legend was written down like a couple
years back
uh they have also like they've been in
the dressing room and feel
people like touching them like touching
the back of their neck and on their back
and stuff like that
um and also another thing that has been
reported a lot of times
is that
if they ever leave the door to the red
rooster bar
closed because like i said that was
where the um the apartment used to be
for like the long family used to run it
back in the early 20th century and
that's where they started locking their
daughter when she would
you know have her episodes
so if you leave that door closed um then
a lot of times like people say that they
hear
it sounds like somebody likes
frantically scratching on the door like
they're trying to get out
so that's another thing that's been uh
reported a lot so like i said i think
i think that this hotel is still
around i don't know how much it is to
stay in it but yeah it has a casino and
a theater and all that kind of stuff
so what'd you miss yeah pinching your
ass maybe that's the first thing i
thought too
and then i was kind of like that's
probably what it is yeah well yeah i
think you weren't in here but um
but i said that some people had reported
having their asses pinched or haven't be
feeling like they were quote unquote
touched in the middle of the night yeah
which as i said i'm not sure what what
the touching entails
like i don't know how happy i'd be be
sleeping and then all of a sudden
feeling some
weird-ass spectral fingers
up in some places
you know what i mean
it might be a little disturbing
went red
oh there it goes
it's back okay
it was funny it just went boom it went
out and it came back
the ghost got ghost got mad ghost got
mad
the ghost of george long got mad because
i was calling him like a sexual harasser
yeah for like touching people's badges
in the middle of the night with their
spectral fingers
sorry george i don't know
what are you gonna do come on it's
almost time for another drink it is yeah
i know
all right so let's talk here's a little
something different because she usually
goes for people right
so i wanted to get here here this
this is something they could talk about
on the animal planet paranormal show
see i thought it was going to be this
kind of stuff this is the legend of the
hell dogs of el dorado canyon
they probably did talk about something
like this but then there's only one
episode c and they got a [ __ ] pack
[ __ ] season after
after season after season see yeah
they're gonna shoot horns they're
getting like all the dregs from the
other all the million other paranormal
shows they're like do you have a cat
yeah yeah we're gonna put did the cat
ever look like like look in a corner
yeah weirdly yeah say that the cat was
like disturbed
yeah yeah yeah oh the cat was very
disturbed yeah
did you have a cat no but there were
mice out in the backyard okay can we say
that the mice
were they pet mice or were they just
kind of not just wild mice and you know
i saw it once and never saw it again oh
so the mice ran away
yeah and my every mouse from miles
around ran away
see so i don't have any pets but you
know i might oh i had a hermit crab
the hermit crab seemed a little
unsettled from time to time
hard to tell though
he kept moving from shell to shell
i just thought of another really dumb
short story
about
about a herbert crab whose shell becomes
haunted so he has to
say he has to keep moving
yeah
he's like haunted shells like moving
that can be like kind of funny i wonder
if anybody's written that one hey chuck
tangle yeah
[Laughter]
you have enough in his ass yeah
yeah
he's gonna have to the hermit crab is
gonna have to go up somebody's butt
first and then it could be haunted
uh but yeah so hal dogs of el dorado
canyon
so uh the kind of the thing about this
place is that
there's it's this kind of it's this
really really big uh area and there's
just a whole bunch of [ __ ] that happened
in this one area so there's all kind of
ghost stories about it but i picked this
one just because
it was a little bit different because it
wasn't people you know what i mean
so
back in the mining days you would have
all these prospectors that were going
out there
mining for various things
and a lot of them would uh keep dogs
obviously to you know help them with
stuff like you know keep people away
from their sites or whatever
so uh so a lot of the dogs were kind of
mean because you know they were trying
to keep trespassers away and [ __ ] like
that
now sadly
when uh you know the mine was depleted
or when the miners moved on a lot of
them for whatever reason didn't take the
dogs with them
so they would either
just kill them like just shoot them or
whatever and then or they would leave
them chained at the site sometimes
they'd release them but sometimes they'd
chain them up and just leave them there
which sam's leaving him to die that
seems i have a hard time believing that
that seems pretty shitty i mean i'm sure
like i'm sure it happened you know what
i'm saying i'm just saying it probably
wasn't i would imagine most people would
would just probably just let him go let
him go yeah you know what i mean because
yeah i don't even think putting them out
of the misery or shooting them would be
this was this is old west yeah i ain't
buying it yeah no
back in the old west they were they they
liked dogs
i was kind of thinking that too that's
where all that man's best friend stuff
was they would have let the dogs go
yeah i mean
if they couldn't yeah if they couldn't
take the dog with them because
i mean having a good dog
that's it's pretty valuable you're right
i mean especially like i said they're
good protection you know it's
companionship it gets lonely out there
yeah no they didn't kill dogs so so i'm
kind of sensing [ __ ] in this i'm
just saying that's what the legends if
you killed a dog
in the old west
that was a killing offense if you shot
somebody's dog oh he'd probably kill you
for that
well documented rightfully documented if
you shot somebody's dog there was gonna
be a gun because that's a pretty shitty
thing to do like shooting somebody's kid
yeah so i'm not buying this that much
i'm suspicious
okay go ahead
thank you
[Laughter]
yeah no they wouldn't shoot dogs unless
leave them changed i'm going no yeah
that seems [ __ ] up unless they were
just really really shitty people i said
you know
i'm just saying i'm not saying it never
happened i'm just saying it was probably
pretty rare and the person was probably
a serial killer yeah
yeah
cause people do it nowadays it's
individual cases maybe that's what i
mean but no it wouldn't be something
that you would be done you know i mean
they would let dogs go
or or sell them
people would take them yeah i mean the
dogs are pretty valuable yeah
you wanted them around a lot of farms
and [ __ ]
yeah rebecca dunn says hi folks running
late if someone shot my dog and it was
legal i'd shoot them also yeah i don't
really blame people for
i don't i don't blame for that at all
because like it's you know and it
wouldn't matter if it was legal or not
in the wet in the old west well she's
just saying nowadays yeah
i mean pets are family members yeah
things with things and it will probably
go back to this eventually anyway
civilizations have legal structures and
when civilizations start to decline the
legal structures change and then it goes
down to just custom
you know what i mean local traditions
and customs and your culture
and people
enforce things based upon that you
really don't need legal systems
most of
humanity didn't have them
over history things were just done by
culture customs and traditions that's
far more powerful
you don't really need a legal system
and that's the way the old west was
although it had legal systems inside
towns
as it got more developed
you shot somebody's dog they'd [ __ ]
kill you
that's the same as you stole a horse
they'd kill you
well i mean that was really
but more than shooting a dog even
killing someone's horse
that was almost that in a way that was
like murder
or stealing a horse or shooting well
shooting a horse would be the same as
stealing a horse yeah unless the horse
was injured and you had to shoot it they
did that all the time yeah but then they
ate the horse
you know you didn't waste that
but
horses were valuable and the steal a
horse was the same as attempted murder
yeah okay yeah they didn't [ __ ] around
if you stole a man's horse what were you
doing you're leaving him to die
yeah they killed you for that yeah and
it was done summary execution in the
field
it didn't take judges or cops they're
just we know you stole that horse we saw
you there's the horse and you're on it
come here and they hung you strung you
up
feet kicking and [ __ ]
is what happened to him you stole a
horse oh okay
well that'll happen that's it yeah yeah
well as i said it'd hang a sign on them
yeah and just leave them hanging in
there you know
that's what they valued yeah i mean you
know and for a good reason
that's why i value your cultures and
traditions
because eventually you might have to
live by them
so there was a story maybe this is where
the idea that
people left the the dogs to die chained
because this story i don't know if this
is where the story originated but this
is one that comes up when you talk about
this legend
so there's these two brothers
and they were um exploring this one area
in this particular canyon
and they found this old mine shaft
and
next to the mine chapter going down into
it was this old chain that was embedded
in the wall like near the entrance of
the shaft
so they go into the mine and they find a
bunch of bones that looked like
the skeleton of a big dog that had been
chained there
so they set up camp
and they're sitting around the campfire
and they hear you know coyotes and [ __ ]
which you know not weird
now they're eating dinner and both of
them
later reported that they started feeling
really
uh weird like unsettled
they said the atmosphere seemed to get
very thick
um and seemed like charged like there
was something in there like lightning or
something
and then they started hearing
something that sounded like dogs panting
really really close by even though there
weren't any animals like they couldn't
see any animals and then they started
hearing a bunch of growling
then even though they could see all
around the campsite they had a fire and
everything and uh they couldn't see
anything they started hearing a bunch of
like paws like circling the campsite
and a bunch of scratching noises
coming from the shaft where the chain
was where the skeleton was
now while they both looked at where the
the entrance to the mine shaft allegedly
the chain
started moving by itself
looking like it was being pulled away
from the wall like something was on the
end of the chain you know what i'm
saying like it was kind of up like that
so at this point uh the guys are like
because the chain is just keeps going
like that like that and they're just
kind of like
yeah um this is getting really weird
they both like jump up and they shine
their flashlight or whatever over there
or the torch or whatever and um
there's like
they saw blood stains and scratches on
this rock
and then the chain drops down suddenly
like as soon as they put the light on it
and then they felt
something invisible but about dog height
running past their legs
ghost dog yeah
so
at this point they were like yeah we're
out so they got the [ __ ] out of there
but they said while they were running
they heard
as though there was like a pack of dogs
or a pack of wolves running after them
but they couldn't see anything
now um
so i guess like the people that live
around there this is a pretty common
legend as far as i could determine uh
but they do call them the hell dogs of
el dorado canyon so it's apparently all
these dogs that died in this canyon for
what for of whatever causes
that are [ __ ] people up i guess
because they were
mean dogs i don't know
but that's why
thank you
so ghost dogs
that's kind of cool that make a good
episode but those old dudes are dead
though huh
well these dudes i think this was kind
of a more recent uh
a recent when was this setting again
well there i mean the legend goes back
to the old west days but i'm not sure
when that particular story was from but
that was kind of one of the more common
ones
sandra says i'd rather have a ghost dog
in the house than a ghost person right i
think that'd be kind of sweet
and i have heard like i have heard about
stories of people whose pets died
and then
they
either saw or felt their pets in the
house
like you know what i mean like even
people i knew they said oh my dog died
and then
and i was really sad about it but then
sometimes i'd wake up and i thought that
i felt his nose on my face or something
like that so you know maybe they can
still haunt you i don't know
so this one this is pretty short
but
i liked this one so much i think this
might be my favorite one just because
this one is
has the creepiest imagery i think
uh this is the death ship of the platte
river wyoming
because i'm always a big fan
of uh death omen
ghosts death ship you know what i mean
like when you see
a ghost or a whatever
and it's like a portent of death yeah i
really like that trope
in ghost stories i don't know why but i
just like that a lot
so
there's this uh the platte river
in wyoming
there's a legend that there's a ship
that sails uh down this river
and
what'll happen from the people that have
seen it apparently
is that there'll be this really creepy
mist that comes out of the water and
then it turns into this big ball of fog
that's kind of like rolling around and
then the ship will kind of like come out
of it all ghostly
now this was my favorite part
the ship
all the ship and the mast and the sails
and everything like that are all covered
with frost i just really like that image
uh and then there's a crew on the ship
who are also all covered with frost
imagine how creepy that would be if you
[ __ ] saw that like just the ship
coming out of the fog and it's all like
icy and [ __ ] i love it i love it
so it's like this was the most evocative
for me because i'm like oh my god i love
this imagery so much right then into a
story i know that's what i'm saying it's
like see this i oh that's this is the
kind of stuff that like that's it i just
love it so yeah so they're all covered
with frost no wait it gets better
so the crew is like all icy and they're
standing there on the deck
and they're all standing there huddled
around
a corpse
that's lying at their feet like with
canvas over them they're like on on a
piece of canvas
now
what happens is
if you see this ship
what happens is that the crew
will part
and they will pull the canvas aside on
the corpse and it will be someone that
you know
and that person will die the same day
that you saw that ship
now this this was actually first
reported
the first uh you know report that i
could find of it was from 1862 and there
was a guy named leon weber who was a
trapper
and he was on the platte river one
particular day and he said that he saw
the ship the frost the fog everything
the crew steps back pulls the canvas
aside
and he sees that the face on the corpse
is his fiancee
and she indeed
died the same day that he saw that ship
there was another sighting in
1887 by a dude named gene wilson who was
a cattleman
and again he saw the ship and uh the
canvas got pulled aside and it was his
wife's face
and she also died later that day
somebody also reported seeing it in 1903
and uh he saw actually he saw like his
best friend he was out there like
chopping a tree or something and he saw
his best friend and again uh the
the person died the same day that he saw
it they said they uh this
ship almost always appears it's almost
always reported
in late fall
and apparently allegedly supposedly
every time somebody sees this death ship
whoever you see
on the deck
is gonna die the same day it's not it's
not you it's it always seems like it's
somebody else like a loved one
i've never heard of what anybody seems
like oh it was my own face because
that'd be super freaky
but it's always somebody else so like
their wife or their girlfriend or friend
or something and then that person dies
like later in the day but it's just i
had to mention that even though it's
short because i was just kind of like i
just love
that
imagery of the of the frosty people in
the frosty boat out of the fog and then
being like look it's a dead person
you know what i mean that would be so
[ __ ] freaky i love that kind of [ __ ]
what's understanding about
that red
red
okay it's coming okay yeah
uh
let's see
i'm trying it yeah then it goes person
rebecca down says i have my cats walking
around my pillow while i'm selling for
sleep
and they've been dead
20 years
yeah
oh
that's so sad
sandra says i've waited for my cats to
show up after they died but sadly they
never did
oh yeah that's a bummer
uh yeah sondra mentioned the flying
dutchman we'll have to do a show about
that one of these i don't think we did
the flying dutchman did we i remember we
did a show we did a show about ghost
ships but i don't think we talked about
did we talk about the flying dutchman on
there that was so long ago
jeez
but yeah that that would actually be
like a cool show to do but
yeah i love ghost ship kind of stuff
like i said i love death omens
i don't know why because i think there's
another one that was in the old west one
that i didn't put in my notes but
there was one i think it's like a more
vanity of american native american
legend
where it's actually kind of like a
phantom bird it's like a crow or
something
but it's like a special crow so if you
see it
it's usually i think it's usually like
kind of a warning but i think sometimes
it's good too like sometimes like it's
good fortune but i'm not really sure i
didn't i just kind of read it real quick
but because like i said i really like
the death of him and stuff
all right so let's talk about
oh mike says my grandmother used to say
when an old owl cries someone close to
you is going to pass that's a pretty
common
legend because i've heard that before
too
and i've even read it in different
stories and stuff i think that's a
pretty common
um
death portent that if you hear an owl
hooting like outside your window
that means someone in your house is
going to die we were hearing that all
the time man [ __ ] over there that's
why i said yeah we would have died like
a million times over because i used to
hear owls all the time oh uh people i
told uh i just told sophie that hey so
where are you on the show people are on
the show asking you about you shoes i'm
out shopping with my mom for
thanksgiving
so that's where she's at it's
thanksgiving tomorrow in case you guys
didn't forget
rebecca dunn says oh my god all the
ships sunk from florida to north
carolina outer banks what a ghost tour
that would be cool i mean
cause [ __ ] man yeah there's so many
shipwrecks
around this coast and on the west coast
of florida too
all the [ __ ] pirate ships and
everything like that there's still all
kind of [ __ ] out there treasure
when i was in st augustine
i think i mentioned this before but i
went to the pirate and treasure museum
and they have all kind of [ __ ] that they
just dug out from rex you know what i
mean yeah cool [ __ ]
the owls does tom know that there's a
free fly event going on for star citizen
i don't know what that is bro
i don't know what that is yeah
sheila anne says creepy there is a ghost
story out of long island based on a
ship's frozen tragedy photos are scary
yeah i kind of
i don't know what it is that's so
fascinating to me about ghost ships
about i think it's the same thing that's
creepy about
dead malls
and stuff because you know it's just
that's it's this thing and it's empty
normally it's you know and just the
thought of it out there in the middle of
the ocean
being empty
is really really creepy
i was watching something on nexbo
earlier today and he was kind of getting
into
the uh
not it's not uncanny valley because
that's something different but it's kind
of how liminal spaces quote unquote make
people uneasy
where it's a place that looks like it
should have a [ __ ] ton of people in it
like a city or whatever but there's
nobody in it yeah and how most people
find that really unsettling
for you know just because your
expectation is yeah yeah that there's
gonna that there's supposed to be people
there
but yeah he was talking about that a
little bit maybe it's a little bit of
that
but i think the the ghost ship
phenomenon
has the added thing of being out in the
middle of the [ __ ] ocean
yeah where there's nothing well like i
said before on some of the shows there
is a [ __ ] town a mining town with
street lights
parking lots whole apartment buildings
downtown
everything there's even cars there under
the ground abandoned
from the 50s and 60s
that's some spooky [ __ ]
right now there's a town underground
totally empty
imagine if somebody abducted you and
knocked you out and put you in and you
woke up in there and you woke up in
there
ooh that's another good story you'll
give me all kind of good short story
ideas tonight
and [ __ ]
you'd be like in a bed and you'd wake up
where the [ __ ] am i
if you were to somehow get a light
source you then find out you were in an
underground 1950s looking ass [ __ ]
town totally abandoned somebody should
make a video game up from that with cars
and [ __ ] street lights and a downtown
and everything it's all just [ __ ]
closed up
nobody in it
come on you can do it yeah okay there it
goes yeah and you wake up and it's
[ __ ] just like
all too closed up there's nobody in it
and it's a 1950s [ __ ] town
yeah you think like you went back in
time or it was a nuclear war i don't
know what i would think and then you
find out that the town is not on the
surface and it's underneath the ground
in a huge open space that was mined out
by a damn mine yeah you just [ __ ] a
brick and then there's roads that lead
out to [ __ ] deeper into the mine
yeah and then an elevator that goes up a
shaft [ __ ]
forever and then there's the surface
that [ __ ] trip and it and it's there
right now
that that's that mine is owned by some
company that shut it down years ago it's
still there
did you have you looked it up recently
i've been trying to find because we've
been trying to find it because you said
you saw a documentary about it a long
time ago yeah it was either on history
channel or or or one of the [ __ ]
discovery channel
and uh i haven't been able to find it
since i think it's underneath the ocean
uh off the coast of louisiana
i think the mine went down oh damn it
went underneath the gulf of mexico and
it's underneath there and i it was
i think a bauxite mine if i remember
correctly if bauxite is what you need to
make aluminum i think it had something
to do with making aluminum
i took chemistry there it went broke
because it just wasn't really made right
and there's different ways to mine it so
they just closed it down but it's still
there
and they had a camera crew in there
showing it it was [ __ ] spooky as [ __ ]
it was like pristine
in total darkness
yeah that's spooky the apartments had
[ __ ] [ __ ]
coat hangers in the damn closet some of
them there were some clothes in there
there were calendars up
people had all their dishware like just
like they were coming back
you know because they wouldn't nobody
told them that it was going to be
abandoned forever yeah they just
washed up closed everything down and
left
well nobody ever came back and still
there
see i think that's what weirds me out
about some of those um urbex videos yeah
where it looks like the people just left
in the middle of
life yeah
because you would think like if they
just packed up and left then there
wouldn't be anything in there but
sometimes it's just i know there's still
toys in the nursery
there's still clothes in the closet i'm
like what the [ __ ] happened to these
people
well what happens is a lot of times it's
meant it's mansions
they go bankrupt they lose their jobs
yeah but they would take all their [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying no they wouldn't
they don't have enough money to move
everything
the kids have all moved away
and
whoever's left there's a divorce
happened
it fell under the control of one person
just [ __ ] it he's like [ __ ] he packed
a couple of bags and walked out of there
yeah
moved to other lodgings he couldn't move
all that furniture couldn't even afford
to move it and then the place they're
moving to
you couldn't fit all that stuff
and here's another thing about the
mcmansion industry because i love this
[ __ ]
what what's up pookie go go around
she's like no you have to open the door
okay she's like it's not the same yeah
okay
okay she's coming around no she's right
there she's talking to her oh are you
talking under there okay she's talking
to the mirror she's talking to the other
pookie talking to the pooky in the
mirror
okay
she's been doing that a lot the last
couple days
i don't know if she thinks that's
another pookie or if she knows that's
her and she's just going hey me
you would think
that uh
you could build a mansion
and then try to sell it and move away
and make money on that mansion
you'll be gravely disappointed
that matching will sit there and no one
will ever buy it
and it's because a person who can afford
a mansion
can afford to build a brand new mansion
to their own specification yeah why
would you want to build somebody else's
janky ass mansion
i don't want your movie theater yeah my
own movie theater so there's a huge glut
of [ __ ] mcmansions with a person only
lived in them for 10 years
and they're kind of made like they're
picked out of a damn catalog they're
just sitting there
and nobody wants them
because they're three million dollars or
a million and a half dollars well for
three million dollars you can build a
[ __ ] another one brand new
yeah kick-ass [ __ ] for three million
dollars that's why
uh what are you doing stop no
you're crazy yeah
she likes spock yeah
so um
yeah
you would think a mansion was worth
something they're not
it's weird it's weird how money works
so um i wouldn't know
well i can understand it
so here's a weird thing
some of these urbex people you go see it
yourself i'm not making this up just go
look at [ __ ] abandoned mansions or
urban exploration
what are you doing pookie i'm trying to
talk to these people
see she doesn't care no she doesn't it's
like i'm a cat yeah
you would think
that you could
[ __ ] where was that
pokey you're making me lose my [ __ ]
place
so they build these [ __ ] matches and
you can't sell them you would think
they'd be worth something but they're
not
oh you can build another one
turn red
come on
there it goes we're way back what the
[ __ ] is happening i don't know so you
think you could build a mansion and it
would you could make money on it and
sell it no
three million dollar mansion that's what
it's worth for three million you can
build another one just like it i mean i
feel like even if you had three million
dollars the smartest thing to do would
be build something like this yeah that
at least has resale value because it's
not important to buy it yeah like it's
not expensive it's expensive but it's
not so expensive that it's out of most
people
exactly
i mean how many people can afford to buy
a [ __ ] three million dollar house
hardly anything you can't get approved
for it
so um
that's the problem with the [ __ ] the
mansion game
so here's another thing that's [ __ ]
weird about the [ __ ] rich people
mansion gang
they by imagine they go on this property
i'm gonna build a three and a half
million dollar mansion they got whole
companies they'll show the whole catalog
and they'll pick everything out by
catalog
and some of these people have terrible
taste
the way the things laid out it's all
[ __ ] wrong
and they even furnish them it even comes
with furniture
but it's kind of like cheap furniture
it looks good but if you actually look
close at it
the quality is not that good and it's
because they don't plan to live there
that long
and they have many of these things it's
not like they have one mansion they
might have four or five of them
and to the person that's building these
things it's not really a home
it's more like an uh a a personal hotel
they're moving from one to the next they
don't really care what happens to the
thing
and they sell it and abandon it they
don't care about that furniture it's in
there it's not really theirs
it kind of came with the house when they
ordered it well when you have that
amount of money nothing really has much
value to you and it's cheesy you don't
need it you could just buy another one
it's that cheap kind of disposable [ __ ]
like you'd get from [ __ ] off of ebay
you know i mean the couch looks good but
you pick it up it doesn't weigh anything
well they don't care they need a lot of
them nobody sits in them
more like a decoration
big glass windows
and what's weird is if you find these
things
sometimes they've been abandoned for
eight nine ten years
and the power's still on
weird you can go in there and turn the
power on you could live in it if you
wanted to
oh believe me i thought of it like
sometimes we see some of the [ __ ] on the
urbex i was like
i could live there living that yeah i
don't care where it is yeah free rent
[Laughter]
somebody shows up he says i'm here from
uh i work for the bank i'm the caretaker
yeah the caretaker
you've always been the character yeah
that's what i would say
uh but yeah
i'm greedy
so uh yeah so what was i talking about
okay
rebecca says i'd like three dollars usd
right now yeah yeah same
uh
yeah rebecca says my father-in-law his
mansion was
huge but the layout was bizarre it
looked like a panic room between one of
the living room to the kitchen it was a
walk-in pantry it made no sense yeah
yeah in melbourne florida hey that's not
that hard
yeah florida's filled with mcmansions
yeah there's a lot of empty ones
but something half that size which would
be kind of like this house this house is
maybe half the size or maybe one third
the size of a mansion that will sell
but as soon as you start getting into
the [ __ ] million dollar plus realm
you just can't get a loan on it unless
you're [ __ ] amazed well rich you know
but jenny and i we're not rich we can
get we can get this and it's
under half a million what is it 475
something like that yeah you can get
that
and the monthly payment isn't that much
well the monthly payment is the same as
we were paying in rent at the other
place right which was a lot smaller so
it doesn't really make a difference so
you know
so so it doesn't make sense like
that makes it right and honestly in
orlando
uh there is not a decent apartment to be
had
for under
twelve fourteen hundred dollars really
depending on where it is but i mean if
you wanna live somewhere
some of the places around like where the
around you where ucf are are okay
and they're not quite that expensive but
honestly i don't really see anything
that's not a [ __ ] no for under 1200
a month and they got and even that's
pushing it they got some real nice
apartments in downtown orlando they're
expensive though yeah they are very
they're very expensive and they're
really they're not worth it
for that amount you could get a mansion
out here
yeah like i said if you're going to pay
that much rent get something for it
right but it's not a big difference
being living downtown and here it's not
far it's not far all right
and
i live downtown orlando yeah big [ __ ]
day well i mean the only reason i would
like that was just because everything
was closer and you wouldn't have to go
you would have to drive as far like i
you know i would like to be able because
like i was saying on the last show i
like to be within walking distance of
things but if you're that rich you don't
need to be walking distance from things
it doesn't matter to you
okay
um
because you can have [ __ ] brought to you
and delivered to you yeah but sometimes
i want to go places i don't just want to
sit around in one place and have things
brought to me there's nothing all that
exciting in downtown orlando yep
yep
the [ __ ] is wrong with this
come on ain't that something red red oh
there it goes it's coming back there's
just nothing that exciting in downtown
well there's nothing all that exciting
in people's houses either yeah what do
you think about it
so it's like sometimes it's nice to have
a change of pace i need to do i just i
just wouldn't pay
that to live downtown no i didn't say
that i'm just saying that's a reason why
people would and i totally understand
that because and especially if you work
down there and you had to like it would
be a lot less of a pain in the ass
that's what i was saying the people that
were doing that were living in those
office buildings but now that doesn't
matter because they're all working from
home on their laptops office buildings
are a thing of the past
technologically obsolete those companies
are going to say we don't need to spend
this kind of money on these office
buildings [ __ ] this we and those office
buildings are all for rent so that's
just going to be rental properties
and who knows if those skyscrapers down
there are paid off
i bet you they're not i bet you they're
not
yeah i wouldn't know i'm imagining
they're probably not
what's funny is that the center the the
reason why office buildings exist and
the reason why cities exist nowadays is
because of those office buildings
and now that those office buildings are
obsolete
the city is soon to follow
the reasons why cities originally
existed because you needed [ __ ]
factories close together to make
products all that's gone
technology is evolving and
away from cities everything being done
locally
in a high-tech suburbia
that's what it'll be sondra says sound
is still there just the picture was
lagging okay all right yeah because
we're not sure so every time
my obs thing goes red i usually just
stop talking yeah just in case it's
hiccups right but
yeah danny rolling ghostface says this
connection is being spiritually oh there
it goes again
i think it right here
uh this connection's being spiritually
diddled by the wild west yeah i kind of
feel like all the ghosts are mad that
we're talking about them i guess yeah
because we don't usually have this much
trouble
um at least tom can't say that it's
because we're talking about something
controversial yeah it is controversial
they don't want me to talk about real
estate values downtown man these [ __ ]
oligarchs yeah but we were only talking
about that in the last few minutes it's
like it's been going off and on like
when we were talking about this got an
ai program i think the ghosts are bad
they got an ai program that's listening
to me ilsa says i still got to
physically go to work i'm a nurse yeah
you know some people do that's what i
mean a lot of people still do yeah
people that work in restaurants people
work in hospitals people you know
there's still a lot of people only a
certain subset of office workers
can realistically work at home a lot of
[ __ ] you got to show up for so
technology dictates reality
and
it's changing
it's not going to look like a lot of a
lot of rich people are going to be
[ __ ]
butthurt
i'm survived at m's i am [ __ ]
surprised that amc survived
you know
amc theaters yeah i [ __ ] surprised it
it survived it almost went under
my understanding people saved it stock
market saved it people started [ __ ]
um buying stock in it
yeah propped up its value well and they
started uh streaming movies as well like
you know you can and you could stream
and buy movies nice to have a physical
[ __ ] high-end theater to go to it is
fun to go to defeat see i said that
before and you argued with me
i like going to the movies yeah it's
good it's it's a good little ritual
i don't know if young people will be
into it it seems like the young i don't
know yeah because i see the number of
all ages in there we'll see
and honestly uh you know
movies that have come out in the last
few years especially the marvel ones and
[ __ ] like that have been
have made more money than any movies
ever so obviously people are still going
to see them
not the last one the last one well no
not the last one but i'm just saying
that in general like in the last few
years the ones that have come out so
there have been like a lot of really
you know billion
three billion dollar movies like lately
in the last few years nonsense pandemic
but yeah see uh you know you can scare
these people into change quickly
deep pattern these [ __ ] if you
don't it's called deep patterning
deep pattern a [ __ ] that's you
know what i'm talking about
uh what do they call it
that um
that cia stuff from [ __ ] mk ultra
they were giving drugs to people to
de-pattern them and make a new pattern
they're talking about like uh to
brainwashing yeah
yeah
it's inherent in the in the phrase yeah
people know that people know what it
means
[Laughter]
yeah rebecca said i remember last year
you predicted amc would fold during the
middle of the pandemic it didn't that
would still go and it was um
it was those [ __ ] um
guys off of reddit
started to meme it back in existence of
that and what was the other one gamestop
the game stop rebellion
they said no we're not taking our amc
away and they just started buying stock
in it
which
popped it back up
which i i commend them for that
it would have gone under though
that other chain went under i think game
stop eventually went under no no no um
the other theater changed yeah the other
one we did this silver one uh [ __ ] man
what was the other what was the other
main one i can't think of oh it was the
second one number two yeah i think that
one under and
what was funny is that that was just
regular people at home
trading on the market through tablets
and [ __ ]
cell phones
said just started betting against a big
old
um hedge fund who wanted to [ __ ]
consume amc and they saved it
which i think that's great i think
that's great because i didn't really
want imc to go away
it's good it's a good theater well and i
really like i mean that amc stubs a-list
is a really good deal
20 bucks a month you can see four movies
three movies a week three movies a week
so 12 movies a month in theory yeah for
the
for the price of less than two movies
yeah
you know what i mean because movies
aren't cheap like to go to the movies so
you're basically paying for a
subscription to like uh
netflix but you're actually able to go
out and do [ __ ] yeah and it's nice for
us especially like you know when we
don't have a lot of money right i was
kind of like oh well there's movies
playing and we already paid for that so
we might as well we just got to pay for
the gas the only thing i don't like
about amc is that they want too much for
that goddamn popcorn in those in those
sodas they need to come down on that
they'd probably make more money if they
came down on it but honestly even with
the a-list you get every you know every
so often you get five dollars or
whatever because i had a five dollar
reward from
a long time ago so i just bought a soda
with that so the soda was like a buck
they need to cut those concession prices
in about half they're not going to
because that's where they make all their
money all their money that's why they
make all their money
they have um
their uh profit margin on the movies
they show is very very very low they
only get a tiny tiny percentage of
ticket sales so they got to make money
somewhere so honestly if you want to
keep theaters open i hate to say because
i know it's really expensive and we do
it too because
we buy candy at cvs before we go to the
movies and like sneak it in just like
everybody else does but sometimes i buy
a soda
sometimes if it's a long movie
uh i will buy a soda because i know or
some tea or something because i know
that i'm gonna get because i'll get
really really thirsty
so i'll buy a soda in that situation
but
it is better for the health of the
theater to buy concessions even though
they are dramatically overpriced but
they're overpriced because that's
where they make all their money just
saying it's just kind of like fast food
places they make almost all their money
on
sodas and [ __ ] because that's that costs
nothing to make and then it's like a
huge markup you know
all right so let me get back to
uh yeah andrea says i would love to go
to amc the one near me only has a few
movies and all the showings are later at
night that's kind of a bummer yeah we
have one that is actually we go to the
same one now that we moved
that we went to from the old house
uh so it's probably i don't know 20 30
minutes away now something like that but
it's a big one because it's like at the
altamonte mall i think it's
how many theaters is it 12 or no it's
18. i think it's 18.
so it's pretty big
and they usually start on the weekends
their showings start really early they
usually start at 10 or 11 in the morning
depending on what not
not so much in the day in the weekdays
but i think on the weekends they start
early or depends on what the movie is
but yeah sometimes i like to go see a
movie just get out of the house you know
yeah and not to like pay because we
already paid we're paying monthly so you
might as well that's how many more cases
we got a lot we got a lot with us bro
let's bring them on it's almost seven
o'clock
oh let's bring it on you the person
that's been talking about lots of other
things
i'll make this show you're making a show
all right so this next one let's talk
about
the salt witch
of the nebraska plains
so apparently i don't know if it's there
anymore
but there was this
uh
right where the saline river goes into
the platte river which is where the
death ship was that we were talking
about earlier
there used to be
this pillar of salt was it lot's wife no
it was just a pillar of salt although
that would be funny if they'd called it
lot's wife
they're saying sneak food in you lose
yeah sneak [ __ ] in sneaking in juji
fruits big old bags of gummy bears
[ __ ] well you go to cvs or walgreens
when they have all the deals oh yeah
they're like three for a dollar a dollar
and one of the boxes yeah of movie
theater candy because they know that
everybody does that i'm saying they're
i'm gonna go get some [ __ ] snow caps
and [ __ ] like i was saying that amc is
missing out because they could sell it
for a little bit more and i if they sold
it for a little bit more
or nearly the same price a little bit
less you mean no if they sold it for a
little bit more at wall than walgreens
did i would say [ __ ] walgreens i'll pay
the extra more at [ __ ]
emc and they would make the money i
think i think i think it's a lot of
people are doing that or a lot of people
just aren't buying anything
i'd bring those prices down they'd
probably end up netting more
they might like they would
because there is this whole
black market under stop black market
yeah this whole underground
of
this is okay
i know we're opening the boxes and stuff
and paper in there so it doesn't rattle
so when i'm walking he's got his whole
system i got a whole [ __ ] because he
has the paint do you have the pants on
now i got one of the pants yeah okay
some of these pants have like a bunch of
pockets and pockets
so he goes to cbs yeah and he's i'll buy
like one like i'll buy a box of m ms or
you know some
pickle
cashews or something
because my purse isn't big so i usually
just kind of have one thing and i stick
in my purse like some m ms or some [ __ ]
so i put that in there he will go to cvs
and buy three boxes usually juji fruits
or mike and ikes or something like that
some of that gross [ __ ] that he likes
yeah
pretty [ __ ] mike and ikes and all the
demons
and he'll take that and then in the car
when we get to the theater we park at
the movie theater and then he has to
maneuver he's like okay i want to put
this in the pocket here and then he
stuffs napkins in the rest of the
pockets so they don't rattle you got to
open the box because he thinks
he's going to get busted
because you're walking because when he's
walking he's going to go
like andy robinson man that's you could
tell that's good in plenty that's the
good thing he's so good at plenty
rattling
you got to tighten them up there's too
much empty space in there yeah
i've taken everything the little
old-fashioned [ __ ] black licorice
[ __ ] candies with the stripes and
[ __ ]
bags and just
a little cinnamon bears and i'll take
anything in there
but you see that's that's money that
[ __ ] amc is missing out on see i will
buy soda or candy in there if i have a
five dollar off thing because i'll get
five dollars off every now and then so
i'll buy a soda or a bag of
chocolate-covered almonds or something
like that if that was a straight-up
candy shop in there they'd be making all
kinds of money
yeah maybe they ought to do that yeah
because you know it's like nobody wants
to pay five bucks for a box of m ms that
you can get from so you could get for a
dollar a dollar yeah at walgreens or cvs
people aren't that stupid
well some people are that stupid i've
seen them in big lines and then they
come back with the little tacos and the
[ __ ] nachos and [ __ ] well i think
that was why
the [ __ ] food well i think that's why
i expanded because that's one kind of
smart thing that amc did was that they
actually did start introducing actual
real food yeah um you know like not so
now they have like artists of like
artisanal pizzas and
all kind of they've hot dogs and [ __ ]
like that and they also have a bar they
have a bar yeah somebody's asking they
have alcohol yeah they got out they have
a bar and and each like it's called
mcguffins mcguffins and then like each
big
headlining movie will have a drink yeah
they have like a signature drink that
has to do with that with the color and
they'll call it like yeah the [ __ ]
slime or ghostbusters slime or whatever
yeah yeah um they're good drinks the
problem is is that they're very weak
and they're kind of they're expensive
well they don't want a bunch of drunkies
like watching trump there but now i
would if this was a tom ross
style organization
no you'd be getting drunk up in there
i'd be pouring you doubles and triples
and [ __ ] you know and and that would
be that would go badly i think because
then in halfway during the movie you'd
start going hey
what's going on and i'd be like oh my
god i'm gonna hit you so hard right now
it would be like that
a couple of the embassies have
restaurants in them where they'll come
they'll bring you food you're at a table
well our uh indie theater in orlando uh
the enzian has that where it's like a
cafe they only show one or two movies at
a time and it's usually like art flicks
or documentaries or you know they do
like retrospectives
i think i saw the nick cave documentary
there a few years back
but so they do that kind of stuff but
they have a whole kind of restaurant and
you know a bar but yeah amc
they actually have real food there
and like pizza nachos
that kind of stuff and they have
a bar
so you can get
we have gotten drinks there before yeah
elsa says she not only takes snacks she
also takes a flask of booze yeah
rebecca's saying take ziploc bags they
don't wrap them that's a good idea
yeah ziploc bag go down in there with
some zip locks and empty all those
things out in a zip line
put them in my pocket yeah rebecca's
[ __ ] keying me out of some cool [ __ ]
there yeah that's how i do it i mean he
will sit there and legitimately eat four
or five boxes of candy gummy candy yeah
how i don't understand how you do it's
fun
well yeah he always gets old man i get
old man well like i said i have a small
purse i don't have a big massive purse i
just have i have a purse that's about
that big you can fit about one box of
candy in there and maybe one little bag
yeah
so i'll usually just get one box with it
because honestly after i have one box of
those i'm kind of like yeah i don't
really want anymore
jenny's [ __ ] with me by eating old
man candy i like i like old-fashioned
candy well i like some old man candy i
like where there's original for example
old man candy
licorice looking stacks that are pink
pink black licorice pink yellow and
green black licorice things and
[ __ ] bitter honeys and [ __ ] what
uh
salt water taffy i like bed honey oh man
candy
gram there's hammer said it's a bunch of
17 year old potheads working at my local
movie theater i'm not too worried about
them busting me for sneaking in some
snow caps that's kind of what i feel
like too i think kids working there
wouldn't give a [ __ ]
but
i feel like also trying to be respectful
yeah i also i feel like it's probably
better not to draw attention to yourself
or not to or not to
you know flaunt the fact
that you're i mean
that you would come in like with a
trench coat like with candy like all in
there and stuff like that give me
[ __ ]
i'm getting away with some [ __ ]
real [ __ ] show up with all that
candy and sell it to everybody
he's a candy scalper yes guys
yeah it just seems a little
we're not really sneaking because
they're i mean even if they kick us out
i don't really care but it's just kind
of like yeah no they wouldn't kick you
out anyway they probably wouldn't even
say anything to you no that's what i'm
saying it just seems a little like you
said it seems a little disrespectful
that's all so i'm just kind of like well
i'll just keep it my person rebecca's
asked where's the old man candy explain
old man candy to her well old man candy
would be like well [ __ ] old [ __ ] old
people like
you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] that nobody would eat and it
was [ __ ] that okay like if you got it in
your trick-or-treat bag you'd be like ah
[ __ ] this
that's not all bad kid old man candy is
the k is the is the is
is there any
traditional american candy that your
grandparents would have eaten or like
your dad would have eaten
those things that are [ __ ]
squares they're blocks and they're
[ __ ] stripes colored stripes
was the oldest man candy ever like all
sorts yeah it's called licorice all
sorts it's got black licorice in it with
stripes of other [ __ ] pink stuff and
yeah all sorts of all sorts that's what
it's called that kind of [ __ ] that's an
old man candy
um
what else is old man candy
root beer barrels ruby barrels although
those are good those are good i'll get a
bat for those i like i like root beer
candy yeah
um
clove gum
yeah
taffy is old man candy some salt water
taffy is good i'm not a fan usually but
some of the flavor is around right jelly
beans maybe maybe jelly beans that chewy
peanut butter [ __ ] [ __ ] although
those are kind of good too yeah old man
candy yeah like you said bit of honey
yeah data honey's old man candy yeah
werther's yeah although those are
delicious clark barr
clark byrne clark barr
does that have marshmallow in it yeah
yeah i think it does yeah [ __ ]
marshmallow
i don't they still make those i think
but i haven't seen one for a really long
time
a [ __ ]
a uno bar and a zero bar those are old
man candies okay well i'm gonna go to
bat for zero they're good no they're
real good because they know candy is
good i like zero bars that's white
chocolate they don't make enough white
chocolate chips although
i will say that in the past few years
a lot of regular candy bars have been
upping their white chocolate game and i
see you i appreciate it i appreciate it
i love white chocolate boxed chocolate
is old man candy that's all man candy
special whitman samplers yeah like the
samplers i used to get one for my
grandmother the jellies are [ __ ]
that's super old man candy yeah [ __ ]
that um i wouldn't even eat those i like
that well what i would get like my
grandma loved whitman samplers okay i
know it's it's a cliche but she did so
every holiday she'd be like give me a
whipping sampler i'd be like okay so i'd
get her one
and yeah they like all the like the
fruit creams and stuff like that i'm
like gross look give me like the good
[ __ ] give me the stuff with the nuts or
the caramel or carrot or coconut was
good too that's good i like them all i
like them all but the ones have fruit
creams and gel in there [ __ ] that [ __ ] i
did not i did not i did not
differentiate
oh neko wafers are a [ __ ] old man oh
that's like maybe the ultimate old man
ultimate old man necco wafers are one of
the oldest that's barely that's barely
food that's 1800s that's barely food
yeah 18 and necco wafers i would maybe
argue that that's not even food i used
to love them as a kid i could still eat
them those little discs waxy i mean you
might as well go back to 1978
go up to
the chalkboard
in your third grade classroom and just
eat the chalk
yes you guys check me on this me you
guys got google go ahead and check it hi
sweet baby
if memory serves
neko wafers are 1800's
they might be it's not even i remember
seeing something about how they were
made they're ancient yeah they basically
just tasted like dust and there's
sadness
dust and sadness they don't really taste
like anything that's the sadness that's
good and they're all different colors as
they're trying to fool you oh they're
different flavors they had a mild
another flavor they had a mild flavor
wild flavor in my ass they don't they
don't taste like anything they were kind
of like antacids they kind of tasted
like like eating pumps
but they had a mild flavor to them [ __ ]
you jenny
[ __ ] you jenny i [ __ ] like those i
like necco wafers they were all i mean
and here's the thing
there's a company out there that bought
all those brands and still make them
yeah andrea just said i found a store
that has all kinds of old candy you
can't find a regular stores yeah you can
get all that [ __ ] on you get it they're
still making it
so obviously there's a big enough it's
an audience for a retro candy and i'm
pretty sure that
i'm pretty sure that necco wafers is
1890s
didn't we see i thought i saw i don't
think it was dan bell but i think it was
somebody like an urbex uh type guy maybe
it was ace's adventures or somebody like
that and i think he they went to this
store yeah
i don't think it was in a mall or maybe
it was in a strip mall but it was like
an old-timey candy yeah shop and it was
big and they had all that [ __ ] yeah i
mean some of these young people don't
know how good
how good real salt water taffy is
saltwater taffy is [ __ ] fantastic
they make good saltwater taffy in st
augustine yeah they said they make all
the scratch there
even like bullshits more modernized
saltwater taffy's good i like that too
they got classic and they got the
nouveau so i like them both
they're both
the new [ __ ] has stronger flavors in it
but the old school stuff is just kind of
sweet and chewy
we're going we got ghosts to talk about
we got ghosts to talk about i'm talking
about this [ __ ] crazy i know it's not
else it's not just me and you it's them
too
they're also responsible oh he's putting
the blame on you guys do you guys hear
that
these damn subscribers
you guys yeah that's all right there's c
address everyone's probably so drunk at
this point yeah i don't know see i just
they don't taste like anything to me oh
[ __ ] danny danny roland goes he talks
about the juice-filled [ __ ] wax
[ __ ] coca-cola bottle i remember that
yeah yeah
i remember that [ __ ] well there were
there were those and then there were
also ones that were just weren't even a
shape they were just like tubes and they
had different colored juice in them yeah
like and they came it looked like kind
of like a calliope situation
kind of like otter pops you used to
freeze those things and then and then
you had [ __ ] had the pixie stix
we had some oh my god otter pops we
didn't have otter pops we had the
off-brand auto pops that you get from
the dollar store and you had the
cinnamon buttons they came on the wax
paper and the little [ __ ] cinnamon
buttons see well they had cinnamon
buttons and they had the other
fruit
fruit with the question mark it's
supposed to be fruit yeah
i don't know what flavor this was
supposed to be but they certainly what
about the cheap imitation eminem's with
the [ __ ] plasticky [ __ ] imitation
[ __ ]
yeah flavor to them the cheap chicken
they were a little bit smaller they were
smaller and harder
terrible chocolate man what was this
called oh
oh it's right on the tip of my tongue
they had m m's i don't know why i almost
remembered this i
the artificial coloring on the [ __ ]
words on the outside of it what was this
called sandra's like what the [ __ ] are
these [ __ ] people talking about we're
talking about real old school american
candy
saunder says google that neco wafers
first produced in
thank you thank you sandra and the ones
that are still for sale today all came
from that year yeah fun facts no
no no
no i just made that
those things are actually good i liked
it
they used to give them away all the time
you could buy them at the corner store
when i was a little kid
you don't see them anymore you have to
order them special
yeah well you know i'm not i think that
was one of the first mass-produced
candies
i think it was too i think i saw
something didn't we see like some kind
of documentary something like that where
they're talking about like old-timey
candy because i'm fascinated by food
history yeah so you know
um do you want to get back to the ghost
are we still talking about although now
i have to pee so talk about this so talk
about candies in tomorrow talk about for
a minute
okay i'm going to talk about candy
deco wafers
sandra's probably not an old west
because it's 1840. yeah this is the old
west thing
so old west canyon cowboys would have
known all about necco wafers
which that behooves
some of you non-americans or even
americans i guess that have never had
necco wafers
to order some you can order them online
and when you get them they come in a
they rolled up in a row
of wax paper and it had on printed on
the outside i think it was red
i haven't seen it since i was a kid i
said necco away first and they would
have like where they were made
they were about the size of a nickel
might be that's why they called him neko
but they were like the size of a five
cent piece nickel
um they were wax
not wax uh
compressed powder
and they had like some light wax over
them to keep it from sticking together
and the flavors were pretty good you
know i mean it was like vanilla and
chocolate and anise which would be black
licorice um
and i there may have been some other
flavors i don't they may there may have
been like a fruit flavor in there
you chew them and they would
crunch and turn into dust
they weren't that hard they were about
they're about as hard as an antacid like
a toms
but they were thin
and uh
you could get a whole roll of them this
big for five cents they were just not
which was even in the 70s was nothing
it was just still overpaid you still
overpaid
when you were a kid if you could
she's looking at it the wrong way i'd
rather buy one jolly rancher you're a
little kid and you got a big piece of
candy and it didn't cost anything really
you're just amazed i don't even care if
it tastes like ass yeah you're gonna eat
the whole thing
i think some of them were mint too
there was mint
kind of like sweet they said but they
all taste chocolate they all taste the
same kind of taste they were weak it was
a very weak flavor yeah
but it was candy
it was definitely candy
cowboys and the ghosts of cowboys would
have [ __ ] know what necco was it was
candy adjacent yeah thank you for like
doing that segway
[Laughter]
it's cowboy candy yeah so uh that's so
next time you're at one of these
locations you can leave some necco
wafers for the ghosts and they'll really
appreciate yeah yeah because they'll be
like oh hey well it went right again
make me want to get some
gross yeah
okay
cowboy ghosts are like hey i recognize
that [ __ ]
neca wafers this is the
in theory
it says reconnections okay so it's back
just back
it uh lost the connection and it's back
whoever owns neko wafers is
[Laughter]
yeah sorry i got waivers you're gross
though yeah
came in he found i was 1847 too yeah
yeah older than i thought they were by
almost 50 years that yeah that actually
is older than i thought they were yeah
yeah sorry about that we had a little uh
hiccup there we didn't say anything no
we were just going oh [ __ ] we lost yeah
that's that's what we were saying the
whole time i was like oh [ __ ] no it's
not going to come back [ __ ] yeah it was
that yeah actually obs disconnected but
it reconnected looks like successfully
um
[Music]
yeah camp guy says my mother remembers
going to her daddy's office and saying
give me a nickel or give me a penny
1930s she could get a whole bag of
candies for a nickel or a dime yeah
yep
andrea smith said when i was a kid a
dollar was a whole pocket full of candy
yeah you get a lot for it
when i was a little kid the high-tech
candy
that broke the [ __ ] entire system was
the [ __ ] jolly rancher
it was little and they were sticks
yeah jolly rancher sticks they sold them
a little squares too like little that
was a little bit after i think those
were five cents when i was a kid when i
was a kid the sticks came out first
and we would get the watermelon the fire
sticks the watermelon strawberry the
pink lemonade just
i don't know if i don't know if they
have that in germany but
jolly rancher was the [ __ ] yeah jelly
ranchers are pretty good i like the i
like watermelon and the strawberry and
cherry flavors for a quarter or 50 cents
you could get a whole bunch of those
sticks and you'd just be happy as [ __ ]
you'd be [ __ ] up the roof of your
mouth suck on the net thing and it was
and it gets sharp it would get sharp and
it would [ __ ]
form to the palate on the roof of your
mouth like a damn [ __ ] retainer and
we go look i got braces and make like a
retainer remember that [ __ ] we were
playing all those games oh my god i
think we used to do that too
now that i'm thinking about it i totally
forgot about that
that's pretty funny
all right so
okay so i'm gonna need a new drink in a
minute okay
like in a minute not right this second
so what was i talking about so i was
talking about the salt which like i said
not lost life although that would be
funny if that's what they called it
so uh so yeah so there's this pillar of
salt
standing on the nebraska plain
um
so the legend behind
this
pillar
is that there was supposedly uh an
indian tribe that lived i don't know
which indian tribe
that lived at the junction of the the
rivers like near where this
where this pillar was soon to appear
so the chief of this particular tribe
was said to be this real mean son of a
[ __ ]
uh you know like respected but everyone
was also kind of like afraid of him
because you know
uh so apparently the only person that
could keep his ass in line was his wife
now his wife ended up dying at some
point and he was so busted up about it
that he basically locked himself into
his lodge and wouldn't come out and
wouldn't let anybody in to see him
because he was dealing with some [ __ ]
you know
now he was in there for so long that
everybody in the tribe was like man what
the [ __ ] is going we need another chief
maybe we need some like chiefing done
and the dude is like not living up to
his responsibilities
uh we get it but you know so they were
talking about that
now uh so that had kind of the the
rumblings of that have been going on for
a while but then the chief comes out one
day of his lodge
and he comes out with all his like war
[ __ ] on like he's going into battle
and he didn't say nothing to anybody but
he just goes
goes strikes out across the plane going
west
he's gone for a month
he comes back a month later
and uh according to the tribes people he
was uh apparently a lot more talkative
when he came back he would he had kind
of gotten over his [ __ ] a little bit
although
what he said he saw i don't know
he
should have been traumatized you'd think
but he came back and he started talking
about what he had seen on his
journey
um
oh another thing he apparently killed a
bunch of dudes too like on this i think
this is just tangential to his thing but
he because he had a whole bunch of
scalps so you know
so he brings back a bunch of scalps and
a big lump of salt
he says
i was traveling over the the prairie or
the plain or whatever
and uh i laid down to camp like to sleep
one night
and i was awakened by this
kind of wailing sound like a screaming
that was very very close by
so he wakes up and then he said that he
saw in the light of the moon
he says he sees this terrifying old
woman
and
she had a tomahawk
and she had this younger woman
down on her knees like by the neck like
that like she's gonna about to [ __ ]
tomahawk a [ __ ] like the old lady was
so the younger woman obviously was just
kind of like [ __ ] like oh me you know i
mean she's like trying to get away and
stuff
now
the chief is like what the [ __ ] what are
these two ladies doing out here in the
middle of nowhere like having this big
uh you know brouhaha so he runs over
there to see what's going on
and uh so the younger woman is like
trying to get away
and uh the older woman has her hand like
all wrapped up in her hair and is
basically gonna like you know split her
head into
now at this point the chief says that he
saw the younger woman's face
and that it was his dead wife's face
and
he's kind of like okay well
this is not gonna stand right so he
jumps on the old lady
and
puts his own like he had a tomahawk too
and he puts it in the old lady's head
right
but
when he did that
uh he did that and then like he tried to
save the younger woman who he thought
was his dead wife
but he said at that moment
it seemed as though the earth sort of
opened up and both the women disappeared
and the spot where this happened he said
a pillar of salt just went
like that and he brought the pillar of
salt like not the whole pillar obviously
but he brought like a chunk of salt back
like as kind of like
here's like proof of my story so for a
long time that pillar of salt stood
there and that was the legend around it
that that was
the salt witch that that was the witch
that because the guy had hit her in the
head
he turned her into salt
and so
for a long time when they would go like
the legend was that when tribes around
there would go to collect salt from this
big pillar
that they would always kind of like beat
the ground around there to make sure
that like the witch wasn't gonna like
pop back out like tom hawk their asses
or whatever so i don't think the pillar
is there anymore
but that was the legend surrounding it
for that it hadn't been there and then
he actually like was like [ __ ] well
like you know and then she turned into a
pillar salt like i said like lat's wife
so i thought that was kind of like a
cool story okay ilsa um you also asked
if
if um
jerky was uh old west candy no it wasn't
jerky was old west mre
that was meal ready to eat that was that
was there yeah that was that was [ __ ]
that you could just take with because
that's like protein and it's easy to
carry and it lasts forever no
refrigeration yeah you don't need
refrigeration you can make it in the
fridge yeah they would make jerky in the
field
it's just it's like an energy bar you
just take meat slice it thin and let it
dry in the sun or you smoke it forever
until all the [ __ ]
until all the damn moisture is out of it
you can eat that
it's mostly damn just dehydrated ilsa
says wait i didn't ask that no you
didn't it was it was rebecca rebecca
yeah okay sorry that was awesome
and andrea said hard tack also
yeah that was what the hell what was all
in heart attack
was just water and flower and
there was something else in there wasn't
it like suet like
beef fatter
yeah it was something like that it's
like kind of kind of made into a brick
yeah made out of the garbage that you
could get at any general store and
anything was left over after you're
cooking and
you could just here make that yeah carry
that that'd be all right it was no
nutrition in that [ __ ]
they didn't know about tradition back uh
they didn't know about nutrition back
then
they'd try to live on any live off of
anything
don't try to live off a heart attack
even back then when it's bad but you
know it's
you'll starve to death eating not eating
that
they're gonna go out like mining for
gold or whatever the hell they're doing
back in the day
and you're gonna be camping out on the
plane
so you gotta take some [ __ ] like i said
like some jerky or some [ __ ] like that
that's going to be easy to carry and
that it's not going to spoil living off
a heart attack it'd be kind of like
living off of crackers
crackers and butter
it's going to be like
i don't think you could do it long term
you die of malnutrition eventually they
did die in malnutrition well yeah they
just didn't know what it was sometimes
they're like well they just died
that happened sometimes i suppose
for how long years
[Laughter]
oh my god i hope nobody ate a heart
attack for years yeah you don't know
what they're doing
they i mean they had some pretty shitty
[ __ ] yeah eating shitty stuff yeah they
didn't know anything about nutrition
well they didn't know any better i mean
you know
i'm not like they didn't
i'm not [ __ ] they weren't dumb it's
just that you know technology hadn't
really progressed to a point where they
didn't have science they didn't know
about nutritional science no of course
not they just knew what tasted good
although heart attack doesn't taste good
though no i kind of feel like maybe the
perception was
well they were getting something to eat
that was easy to carry that you could
just like stick in your pocket and it
was cheap and it was cheap and it lasted
forever so you can eat it so therefore
you ate something
they didn't know yeah they're like well
it's better to eat something rather than
right
they didn't know
which in general that's true
i'm just saying that if you're going to
be out in a canyon mining for months at
a time
probably you're going to get rickets or
some [ __ ]
yeah well
get scurvy too if you're not getting any
vitamin c
that was what i was just going to say
you probably get some scurvy also you
couldn't live off of uh jerky but you
would live you could live a lot longer
off a jerky
yeah you probably could you need to get
citrus in there and you need to get some
vegetables which they did that
uh well [ __ ] man even back in the hard
times well even back in the old days
they knew about i mean the pirates and
[ __ ] like that knew about scurvy because
they'd always like bring citrus fruits
limes and [ __ ] yeah and they always you
know they supplemented their diet with
that because they knew what would happen
if you didn't have
citrus
you know yeah but who knew what dudes
out in the old west knew
that's just some of that but they didn't
know everything that's the thing not all
of those dudes it's very easy to think
like nowadays information is just
everywhere and it's very easily
disseminated back in the old days you're
kind of like well you know pirates in
the 16 and 1700s knew about scurvy
um but
would they i mean
would some random dude in the old west
have necessarily known that maybe not
ram dudes in the old west mostly just
lived off things like rabbits and fish
and
the occasional deer
and uh they'd trade with indians and eat
things that indians gave them which were
kind of like a pumice thing little
[ __ ] biscuits with damn nuts and
fruit in it or berries in it
and uh maybe there's some pieces of meat
in it and they go that don't taste all
that good but get here eat that you know
what i mean there's
[ __ ] like that although i feel like back
then they probably didn't have real
discerning power
they just ate
i mean one they probably smoked like
chimneys so i don't even know if they
could even taste anything after a
certain point
so and they were used to shitty food
it's not like they were
you know it's not like they'd live their
entire lives up to that point being
foodies and like you know
they enjoyed meat cooked over fires
which everybody has been doing that for
thousands of years which i'll admit
that's that's pretty damn good they
preferred that over even nowadays we'll
grill a steak yeah every now and then
they prefer that's delicious they
preferred that over anything that and
fish over fire
and then they carry coffee with them
and make coffee
cowboys carried coffee though that blew
people's minds yeah but no they carried
coffee cooking a pot they had different
ways of cooking it they'd overcook it
they'd re-cook those [ __ ] coffee
grounds or beans or cracked up beans
they'd cook them four or five times try
to get more coffee out of them i imagine
that [ __ ] got bitter as [ __ ] bitter as
[ __ ]
they weren't coffee connoisseurs they
just were trying to get every bit of
[ __ ] that they could that's what i'm
saying it's not like oh every day i'm
going to get my you know cinnamon dolce
de leche or latte or whatever and then
like suddenly oh now i have to go out
the canyon and i'm gonna drink this
shitty ass coffee
you know they were just used to drinking
it like that i don't think they i don't
even know if they had a conception that
[ __ ] could like actually taste good
oh no they knew just
they knew they knew that meat tasted
good they knew bread and
stuff like that and honey they knew but
just
they ate what they could get yeah when
they got out to sierra nevadas and
really good parts of the united states
there's a lot to eat out there they were
eating pretty well
you know so
they had skills
fish meat
rabbits squirrels you know they eat
pretty good yeah i mean even like just
fish over a fire oh yeah is really good
yeah they eat a lot of them even without
a lot of seasoning and people forget
that they could fish they knew all about
fishing
they may not fish what you know the same
way we fish now i think they mostly
fished with nets
and traps but they could get fish
although i'm fishing the hook with a
pole that was 1800s they knew about that
too
yeah i mean that seems a pretty obvious
thing you don't need a fishing line they
could just well i mean the native
americans were fishing yeah you'd think
that they would have picked that a lot
of times they used a basket
to fish
you know that yeah it's like a net it's
like a basket and they put that in a
place where water was going on and
they'd wedge it between rocks and wait
for a fish to get caught in it and pull
the basket out and then put it back and
they do that in the rapids yeah
it's an easy way of doing it
yeah like that totally makes sense um
chase him up on the shore that's another
thing too you may put a bunch of sticks
in the ground to make a wall
and let him go in it's up near the bank
especially
then the place where the wall has an
opening in it
you can walk around and you get in that
opening and close the opening and chase
them up onto the damn bank that's where
those fish are like oh you [ __ ] we
fall for that every single time yeah
right there's a bunch of different ways
to do it poor fishes
too bad they're so delicious yeah
i might need another drink i think okay
all right so let's talk about
this was kind of a cool story i like
this one
this is the legend of silver heels
so this happened in a place called with
the fabulous name of buckskin joe
colorado
this was in 1861.
so this woman arrives uh
sadly her real name has not been
recorded
she was just known as silver heels she
uh was a dancehall girl
she came into town
on the stagecoach
and she was apparently
the most beautiful girl that anybody in
this town had ever seen
uh this was a mining camp so she comes
in there
and she starts working at you know the
dance hall i don't know like nobody
knows why she's called silver heel heels
presumably because she had like silver
dancing shoes or whatever um but that's
the only name that anybody remembers her
by
uh as i said her real name is not
recorded
so she actually
just came into
buckskin joe for a limited engagement
but because the people in the town thank
you
because the people in the town thought
she was so beautiful and they loved her
so much they begged her to stay
um they just like gave her all this
money and presents stuff please don't
leave
so she's like okay well i'll stay here
and you know continue her
her engagement uh dancing
now winter of 19 of 1861 rather came and
uh the town was stricken with a smallpox
epidemic
so
basically it was really bad like there
was just pretty much everybody got sick
overnight it was uh it was terrible
now there were just numerous numerous
deaths now silver heels to her credit
she was one of the people that stepped
up
and
pretty much like
what played like ursat's nurse to a lot
of people who were sick
um you know because they sent to other
cities for nurses but they had their own
problems and they didn't send anybody
so basically people in the town that
weren't sick
you know they were kind of asking them
hey please can you help us out with like
all these sick people
so silver hill stepped stepped up and
she just went to everybody's house and
was like helping everybody out that was
sick doing what she could do even showed
that she was quote unquote just a
dancing girl but she apparently like
really stepped up and did all this stuff
now she just
you know stayed in everybody's houses
she was apparently not worried about
getting sick herself
um which apparently
she did i don't they don't know exactly
what happened to her in the end they
think
that what happened
was that
the epidemic had mostly passed by the
time uh the spring of 1862 uh came along
now
by that time silver heels they're not
really sure what happened to her but the
the most common story is that because
she had spent so much of her time
tending to people with smallpox that
obviously she had probably contracted
smallpox herself
um nobody really thinks she died of it
they think that she got it and recovered
but if you don't know smallpox a lot of
times if you got it and recovered it
would really [ __ ] up your face
a lot of times and um so they think that
this is what happened to her like she
had like her face was disfigured from
all the
smallpox
wounds or whatever you want to call them
um and that she didn't want anybody to
see her
so they think that maybe that's what
happened to her that she kind of went on
the down low because she kind of been
known for being
so beautiful and she got smallpox and
you know she didn't look the same as she
looked before and she didn't want
anybody to see her face
so
but apparently like a lot of the miners
looked for afterwards because they're
like well we don't care if you look ugly
now we still love you yeah you're still
awesome
um they went to her house and it had
been cleaned out like she moved but they
couldn't find her
um they didn't think that she'd left by
a stagecoach nobody had really seen her
leave the town but they didn't really
know what had happened to her
so
like i said it maybe
i don't know if she died
i mean if she died you think they would
know but i think what happened was that
she got smallpox and got the [ __ ] out of
there so no one would see her because
you know they were used to
seeing her the way she used to want to
let down the fans yeah i kind of feel
like that's what it was but it was kind
of sad because a lot of the people in
town allegedly uh this is a story anyway
a lot of people in town still wanted to
find her like they you know because
they're like well you're still awesome
we don't care like what you look like
but um
they did say that a couple years later
that there
uh was seen in the cemetery in the town
that there was a woman that would come
there sometimes that had like a whole
bunch of like black veils over her face
so they thought that maybe that was her
um and she didn't want anybody to see
her
now because everybody in this town loved
her so much
there was actually a mountain a mountain
like local to the town and they named it
mount silver heels after her now
as i said when they thought they saw
this woman in the cemetery that they
thought was her that's when she was
still alive presumably
but
later on and even into recent times
it's very common for people to report
seeing a heavily veiled woman all in
black walking through the cemetery in
buckskin joe colorado carrying flowers
and they think that this is probably her
now they say if you go up to her that
she'll disappear
um
but you know as i said because she
thought that
i don't know i guess she thought
everybody just loved her because she was
beautiful
um and then when she wasn't beautiful
anymore she's like yeah don't look at me
anymore and then she just like went into
hiding but so i guess when she died but
a lot of people have said that she still
uh haunts the place or particularly
haunts that cemetery and maybe is
visiting the people that she tended to
like before they died of smallpox
now there's another guy
this is very this is very weird
there's another ghost sort of
in the same town this is another legend
about this uh town buckskin joe colorado
now there was this dude
named jade dawson
hidgepath hitchpath i think was his last
name
and he comes to this town uh looking for
gold he was a miner
and he was looking for a wife also
now what ended up happening to him
though sadly was that in 1865
i guess he had been
uh
trying to um
prospect for gold on the side of a
mountain
uh but without a buddy i guess and he
had fallen
so he they actually found his busted up
body uh on the bottom of mount boss so
he'd been prospecting for gold up there
and he fell and he died
now
after he so they found him and they
buried him
and then this is so weird this is like
the first time i've ever heard of this
type of thing happening
so they buried him
but then
apparently
his bones
turned up
in
the bed of a prostitute
in the next town over come on now
now
everybody in town just thought somebody
had like dug his ass up and put it in
somebody's bed like as a joke
yeah but the [ __ ] kept happening
apparently so the story goes so they
think that this dude was such a poon
hound
that his bones
just keep turning up i gotta get these
in the in various beds in brothels
that's what i thought of i was like oh i
got to put that on the show that is
funniest [ __ ] out of here i gotta get me
something
elsa says his bones apparently so
apparently
they keep re-burying the dude
and
every now and then like some you know
some sex worker will be like going back
to her bed and the broth they'll just
play ah jesus
i'm ready for you man
jump on this boat
get
working see i thought you'd like that
yeah but is it that just i paid
money's on the money's on a nice day
yeah
i i said i definitely have to add that
story because that is hilarious that
it's like his little bones are so horny
yeah he's gonna but he can't even stay
in the grave his little skeleton has his
little disarticulated skeleton has to
dig out of the grave and go like lay in
the prostitute's bed
i'm ready for you ladies i'm ready
first of all i don't believe this
[ __ ] story and i want to be it's a
good story it's a good start
it's made in honor of some dude that
foot was a poo in half
yeah you know they still find him and
then he said back every day he's up here
we can't even we can't even keep him in
the grave yeah i don't even know turn it
up in all kind of like hookers beds all
over the town probably not based on a
real man it's ilsa says old horny bones
yeah
it's just a story that dudes would
relate to oh yeah i know a guy just
liked it
it ain't me though
death won't stop him yeah
i just i find that delightful that is a
delightful story yeah
that is just and i had never heard that
of actual that's not even actually
really a haunt well it's kind of a
haunting but you don't really hear about
people's bones walking around trying to
get laid and trying to get laid that's
why that was new on me so i'm i'm kind
of into it exactly like something i like
that story that is exactly the kind of
ghost story that dudes in the old west
would tell
yes i think that's kind of why yeah
every time
they mo they're more sporting gals and
find him in bed over and over again
oh hell yeah i heard about that i heard
about that yeah
for all i know i might end up like that
after i die
that's like some [ __ ]
old west dudes to talk about
and they'd be like oh yeah we we better
hope we better hope that's what it's
like yeah
pass me a coffee
that shitty ass coffee
damn this drawing
that we've i've got some of that new
high finger
what they call sanitary paper you
you wipe your butt with it
medicated
yeah always a lot better than the corn
cob it's a lot better than it got some
aloe and [ __ ] in there
it's paper but it's kind of soft
you try some of that who the [ __ ] some
of this
look at that that's hygienic smell
oh yeah smell that actually yeah doggy
that smell good
hold on one second
i'm going to try this out
don't you look now
put some coffee on i'll be back in a
second
i'm just going to go over here
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's funny because like toilet paper now
it seems so obvious
i guess not no
it's hygienic
hell yeah it's hygienic maybe they you
know they talk that [ __ ] up smell that
oh yeah ain't that something how much
you call it how much you pay for that
damn that's steep man i don't know if i
pay that you're so fancy
i pay that
yeah it comes in its own box and
everything
the doctor told me to use it
because i got piles yeah yeah
and you know you know i had them saddle
soaring and getting sore up in the
saddles and my hemorrhoids and
everything doctor told me to use that
yeah
i'm sure they had probably [ __ ]
hemorrhoids out the wazoo you wouldn't
think
yeah being all at one horseback all the
time yeah not
not really having modern laundry
facilities god who knows everybody was
just so covered with [ __ ] which
disgusting germs wouldn't surprise me if
a lot of those dudes are just riding
around with leather pants no underwear
yeah can you imagine that just like
i would not want to see like a scratch
and sniff western documentary and then
those dudes didn't shave
and they didn't have toilet paper so
it couldn't have been good
it and then they took a bath with their
clothes on that was another one that
blew them [ __ ] up washing my clothes
and my body at the same time yeah they
were just getting the water fishing they
just getting a water dirty as [ __ ]
water
well it was water that was like reused
from like the last dude right i don't
think they bothered
or in the field yeah they just get into
a [ __ ] muddy stream with their
clothes on and go
and [ __ ] and take a bath with their
long hair
with their long shots well i mean that's
better than not
than not doing that yeah i'm just saying
it's probably not
what's funny
is this is the victorian era
they're kind of like uh they're kind of
worried about [ __ ] nudity
so you know i mean they left the long
johns on in front of other men
bathing in the
stream for summer because even old west
they were like no homo
[Laughter]
hey love you over no hormones
y'all might be looking
[Laughter]
i mean me looking at my bones yeah yeah
you should have put it do you have a
cowboy hat you don't have a cowboy yet
no i thought you should have worn that i
didn't get a cowboy yeah that's what i
thought i feel like you should have one
but you don't
elsa says while he's using the toilet
paper the other guy breaks out his
guitar and sings the ballad of old horny
bones while the coffee's brewing
i'll be back in a minute we'll talk more
about it
hey next time some heart attack
cowboy movie hey in a couple days we
gonna be able to we could be up and
[ __ ] and
we've been silver creek you know you're
gonna be chasing them calico girls you
know there's nothing but tail up there
oh i know
i know
they got nothing but sporting gals up at
that town sporting gown fourth threat
it's going to be great
you got money yeah i got money
[Laughter]
going make more money playing cards too
camp guy is quoting from canterbury
tales about [ __ ] three great turds
except in old english it's an old
english talk about [ __ ] in great three
games yeah have you ever read the
canterbury tales that shit's [ __ ]
fail faith
it is yeah we read it in high school
but yeah yeah
it's we we had a great time with it it's
it like i said it's in old english so
you have to like know what all the [ __ ]
is is it in old english or middle
english i can't remember
but uh yeah it's all it's it's [ __ ]
filthy it's all about pooping and saying
cam guy says they eating what they did
it probably [ __ ] just came out and
pellets like a [ __ ] rabbit probably
probably yeah it probably did yeah i
mean honestly
which is gross to think about but i
guess that was like i don't know
i guess that was the best we could hope
youtube algorithm did not like me
talking about pooping or canterbury
tales or something
somebody's upset
i don't know
i know it doesn't have anything to do
with anything i'm just like i'm getting
into like tom's conspiracy theory that
that it only does that when we say
something controversial if somebody says
it doesn't like obviously that's not
what it is but
because i'm just talking about random
[ __ ] i'm talking about a skeleton that
like hops to other to different
prostitutes bed for christ's sake
all right so let's talk about uh let's
see let's talk about deadwood
and the bullock hotel
so uh
okay so deadwood probably one of the
most famous old west towns
so in 1876
these two guys show up in uh
deadwood south dakota and their names
were seth bullock and saul star
now they had had a hardware store
in helena montana
and uh they came in their little wagon
with all their [ __ ] like in the back of
the wagon now as soon as they get to
deadwood
they pretty much set up
what what nowadays you might call like a
pop-up hardware store so they brought
all this stuff from their hardware store
and they're just like hey come and get
your chamber pots and all this other
kind of stuff so everybody came around
so they like started selling their stuff
so uh what they did was they bought a
lot
um on a corner
and uh they built a new store like a
hardware store and a warehouse
there in deadwood
now uh seth bullock had actually been a
sheriff
prior
uh in montana
and what happened uh was that after wild
bill hickok who you know very famous
wild west dude he died in 1876.
so um they're like okay well we need a
new uh you know we need more law and
order around here so seth bullock gets
appointed as the first sheriff of
deadwood like a few months after wild
bill hickok died
now uh seth bullock was apparently kind
of an intimidating dude he was kind of
like real big
had this kind of like scary eyes and he
was just kind of like one of the kind of
you know old west type of dude
um
one of the quotes that i found on
legends of america was his grandson said
about him he could outstare a mad cobra
or a rogue elephant okay so he was a
mean [ __ ] shut your mouth yeah
he was
uh so he uh appointed a bunch of
deputies and he's gonna like clean up
the joint this sounds like a western
movie but that's why all the western
movies are like this because this is
some [ __ ] that really happened yeah well
dude comes in because this is all [ __ ]
up i'm gonna give her these losers yeah
i'm gonna like [ __ ] work that was
actually that [ __ ] did happen we're
gonna establish some [ __ ] order into
this [ __ ] yeah that's what he said
so he got a bunch of because apparently
this place before that was just kind of
like woo but he's just like [ __ ]
running a muck you know yeah
so uh he did kind of like crack down and
get some [ __ ] together
uh while uh while running the hardware
store with his with his buddy his
partner yeah
so uh so they have this hardware store
and then like the the back of it was
like a warehouse and then the front was
the hardware store
now 1879 just like i mentioned earlier
it seems like every major town in the
old west completely burned to the ground
at some point
it's just like every single one yeah
deadwood again no exception
uh burned to the ground mostly in 1879.
uh the hardware store
didn't burn down that time
uh but in 1894 there was yet another
fire
just stop it you guys stop building
everything out of wood and oily rags and
drinking and knocking lanterns over
every five seconds they couldn't have it
i don't like no electricity i guess not
it's more of more why does this keep
happening
lack electricity anything else yeah
as soon as electricity became dominant
fires [ __ ]
started [ __ ]
disappeared that and building codes they
built [ __ ] right next to each other so
if one bills didn't cause fire the other
one would catch it then well yeah that
was another thing too it's just crazy
well [ __ ] man that even happened in big
city like london and [ __ ] like that it's
like one building caught everybody's
like well we're [ __ ] that's it it's
just too [ __ ] close together yeah
yeah they didn't really think about it
which you think they would have thought
about it because it's like well there's
fire in every single house
always well it is understandable
you're a dude right a dude
and a dude buys a piece of land and he
goes i'm gonna build something on this
land even though it's a tiny piece of
land in between all everything else
yeah he's gonna try to make his [ __ ] as
big i'm gonna squish my [ __ ] right here
yeah right that's what's happening and
i'm gonna set fires inside it to cook
[ __ ] and the light [ __ ] [ __ ] goes up and
this one burns down oh well
gotta have building codes
romans knew that
yeah yeah wow even though their [ __ ]
burned down too well yeah it still it
happens well even nowadays we have what
happens yeah um but you know you can't
prevent nature right it's just that
don't tempt it you need a [ __ ]
to say no
that's what it is you need to have you
got to have a [ __ ] say no
so when something happens and
i want to buy this piece of land you got
to go no
because i know what you're going to do
with it
okay
yeah you're gonna put something there
and we gotta empty this [ __ ] out
okay
that and and that eventually happened
you know in in cities as people would
just say no
that that lot is part of this lot now or
where to cut it down in half you cannot
build anything there it's too [ __ ]
crowded
and over over the decades
towns loosened up where there was
distance between things which is good
right because like i said you don't want
a whole you don't want one house
catching fire and then like burning the
whole [ __ ] city down six inches which
happened a lot back then like i said in
the old west right one building caught
fire the whole town had burned down a
whole town of burndown because they
built everything right next to each
other yeah
so yeah 1879
big massive fire uh hardware store
survived that
uh but
guess what 1894 there was another one
another fire
uh this time the hardware store did not
survive
all that was left was the warehouse in
the back which was actually made of
brick
but everything else burned down to the
[ __ ] floorboards so you know there
you go
so what happens seth bullock uh and his
partner in the hardware store it's all
star
they're like okay well what we i guess
they still had money or they had really
good insurance or something because
they're like they just lost all their
[ __ ] but okay
they're like we're gonna build the best
[ __ ] hotel that deadwood has ever
seen i don't know how many hotels and
that would probably not have seen that
many hotels that's what i mean so but
they're gonna like we're gonna build
like some fancy ass [ __ ] up in here
um so they're gonna build that over
where like where their original store
was
so they i mean they went all out this is
some [ __ ] they brought in [ __ ]
uh like this fancy ass
marble stuff like her sandstone
from boulder canyon
they built this whole they had this big
restaurant that you could like 100
people could sit in there they had
lobster and pheasant and all that kind
of [ __ ]
red velvet carpet big brass chandeliers
yeah this place is pimping yeah it's
yeah they pimped it out okay sixty three
rooms that's a big ass hotel for this
time money going through that's what i'm
saying
who's staying in this place yeah
i mean it's one thing if what you have
like was this the one hotel that like
the fancy ass people would stay in right
and then you had the one hotel that was
like the you know the super eight or
something that like the
the [ __ ] jenkins people in the 70s
yeah well 1890s 1890s 1890s during this
time detroit was booming
yeah so i'm sure that i mean obviously
they had enough money to like do this
[ __ ] yeah there was stuff in the 1890s
that [ __ ] was built in detroit is
still [ __ ] beautiful today they're
trying to restore it companies went in
there and bought it there's libraries
and hotels that type of [ __ ]
so i know the kind of buildings they're
talking about they were [ __ ] wild you
know wild wild but you have to have a
lot of foot traffic and they have to
have a lot of money going through there
i don't understand it i mean
was it
that's what i'm saying right i'm kind of
like i mean 63 rooms
63 luxury rooms
that's a hard ask that's like something
you'd put in old new york or old detroit
or old chicago in a big city yeah
because obviously you'd get a lot of
people coming through there dead what i
don't know yeah
deadwood doesn't exist anymore well no
it's not there anymore yeah but
yeah building it back then
in the late 1800s early 1900s yeah quite
a gamble i don't know man they're just
saying like each floor like look this is
what it said each floor had a bathroom
which you know this was a little bit
before every room had a bathroom
everybody had like a pot with water in
it and like a [ __ ]
you know a pitcher with water or
whatever you just washed up in that but
every single floor had a bathroom
somebody used that so that was like
super fancy at the time
big old piano in the [ __ ] lobby all
that kind of [ __ ] had a library
everything
super fancy
um
yeah so
apparently this was the place to go if
you had some money and you were coming
to deadwood for whatever reason
now they also uh they also bought in
1900 there was a little building that
was next to the hotel and they bought
that
and they turned that into a bar
so there was that too now seth bullock
who is one of the owners uh he died in
1919
and uh you know was kind of buried out
there later
now um like kind of close to where he
lived like on this ranch
now the thing about it though even
though he was buried out by his ranch
which is not
in deadwood
um a lot of people have reported
that seth bullock still haunts the hotel
that he built because apparently that
shit's still there
um
yeah so i guess this like i said i guess
this hotel is still there so apparently
it's been going all that time
um yeah it's still there's a bar there
and everything there's a restaurant and
whatnot so some people have said that
they've seen the figure of seth bullock
who's a very distinctive like i said he
was a big dude and he kind of looked
really intel like uh really intimidating
like he had really like gray eyes and he
was always kind of like like he always
kind of looked like that
so a lot of people have said that
they've seen him
kind of walking around the hotel they've
seen him in the restaurant they've seen
him in the basement
and uh apparently
the people that work there
they say that
seeing his ghost is more common when
people are like [ __ ] around yeah so
apparently seth is there like managing
the [ __ ] from the afterlife why are you
guys like on this planet what are you
doing like why are you just [ __ ] that's
what i mean so so they do report well
like when they're just like farting
around on their cell phones or whatever
like seth will show up and be like glare
at them you know like what the [ __ ] yeah
so it worked
right so they've reported that it's like
more common than so he's just like
keeping [ __ ] under control he's like i'm
dead but i'm still i'm still watching
you [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like keep you know watch like keep track
of this [ __ ] um also there's been some
poltergeist activity reported
um in the restaurant people have said
that like plates and glasses have like
flown around
uh you know or shake on the shelves that
has been reported multiple times
um
also reported multiple times appliances
and lights turning on and off by
themselves
um ship moving around when nobody's
looking at it uh showers turning off and
on that kind of stuff so like i said
poltergeist activity very common uh in
that hotel
what and i was just gonna say uh
make sure if you guys are enjoying the
show to drop jenny up from the super
chat in the comment section it would be
much appreciated oh [ __ ] we're maybe
only uh we're not even really we're
halfway through the material now well a
little bit more than oh yeah so we we've
got
probably at least an hour and a half for
the show left
which is scary because we're at three
hours yeah but you know that's what
happens we have long shows it's holidays
you know what i mean it's a holiday
holiday so i'm passing around i'm asking
to pass around the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] tray the plate pass the
plate around we're gonna get some i got
some turkey for y'all
i'm gonna feed turkey to everybody okay
after this somehow we're gonna pretend
we're gonna push it at the camera
i had to [ __ ] uh hit facebook
tomorrow and ask if anybody needs
[ __ ] thanksgiving what do you think
you probably should i mean all our
friends have thanksgiving i know but if
somebody well you know
honestly this house is so big we have so
much [ __ ] food yeah we should have
thought of this before now actually
right
i actually thought of it earlier because
we got a lot of food because a friend of
her i think it was tiff the uh the
bartender eye bar yeah she opens her
nose she opens up her house every year
for people that don't have a place to go
um
so you know so probably we should do
that too we'll see i'll check see if
anybody needs anywhere to go because
like i said we have so much [ __ ] i
mean i don't want to put it out just to
everybody on my friend's list because so
many people i don't like
i'll put it out i know i do like you
know well you know you can post things
that are invisible to certain yeah you
know right
because then all of a sudden i have some
[ __ ] how about oh you no
some weirdos showed up at your door no
thanks and then you're on my friend's
list but yeah i don't really watch
this [ __ ]
i mean i don't know if anybody's going
to want to come all the way you know
angel's [ __ ] she's got thanksgiving
she always good things and then you got
[ __ ] you got [ __ ] walker okay he's
with his woman and they got thanksgiving
who else do we even [ __ ] know i mean
we know lots of people you know lots of
people but they're gonna all gonna have
it you know i mean laura and her and her
husband are they hiring her
no i actually had thanksgiving with them
one year like it was a long time ago
yeah yeah like 10 years ago maybe and i
would thank the demetri and his and and
his wife and his kids well they usually
have thanksgiving with his parents
enough his parents i think i think her
parents are in pennsylvania i want her
little swallow got thanksgiving
oh i don't know
because his mom passed away yeah so i
don't really know what's going on maybe
you should check with them maybe she
wants to come check it out as well right
now
honestly um oh i forgot to tell you
honestly it's like we're just like
having a discussion here but well
because i'm in here working most of the
day so i'll get like talk to him much
um my sister
is coming down on vacation
this weekend
um
so i might go to my mom's house in ocala
on sunday
if she's going there this sunday maybe
i'll see what time she's going to come
down she's she lives in atlanta
um
because honestly the whole week she came
down she booked a whole week at uh the
disney parks so she's staying at the
disney parks so she has mostly like [ __ ]
going on at the disney parks and i can't
afford to go to the disney parks
so um so i'm either gonna have to see
her at my mom's house
on sunday in ocala
or
i might have to drive to daytona
on friday to see her at my brother's
house so i'm going to see like what
she's doing because i do want to see her
because i don't get to see her that
often
um
but you know
so either sunday
i'll have to drive to ocala or friday
i'll have to drive to daytona we'll see
all right
davidjune says mimi shows up
somebody said she'll probably jump into
the stream here in a minute she's in the
car oh okay sounds good that's
good she's listening to last week so i
was like what are you talking about you
need to listen to the [ __ ] what the
john teeter one yeah i think so yeah
we got
a lot of our regulars
are behind
okay i see it
i'm off i can't understand it [ __ ] turns
red we'll wait for that [ __ ] to come
back i mean it was
it went down to zero but it's keep it's
coming back it's just yeah
yeah it rarely stops right forever it
usually just like it'll go down it comes
back yeah i don't know if you guys heard
what i was saying i was saying that
sophie's in the car with her mom she's
actually gonna come in in a bid okay but
we got a lot of people that are lis
always listen they're like three weeks
behind i mean to be fair
uh to everybody yeah we put out
a ridiculous amount of content
i mean honestly like i you know what's
stupid i kind of feel like oh that's
still not enough i need to put something
up every day they can't keep up with it
which is dumb
because like i look at other channels
that i like
and they'll put up like one video a week
two videos a week we put up stuff like
five days a week yeah and some of that
[ __ ] is like five hours long
and i'm kind of like
dude i can't even keep track of like all
like the handful of channels that i like
i can't even watch like 20 minute videos
like i'm behind on all that [ __ ]
right so
i can't imagine
what it must be like because i don't
even follow that i mean i have a lot of
subscriptions channels but there's only
like a handful that i follow
like religiously
um
you know they'll put up a 20-minute
video i'm like oh and i'll se i'll save
it to my watch later playlist and then i
watch later playlist is like super super
long because i just never get a chance
to do it but so so i get it i don't know
i don't know why i'm like this
that i feel like
however much we do it's like never
enough do you remember back when we
first started the show we did one show a
week this this one the episode
and then they're like oh we should start
doing movie reviews so we did that
and then just it just kept
going on and on and on and now now we do
[ __ ] their [ __ ] going up pretty much
every day
you know what i mean even even days that
we don't stream thursday and saturday i
record things to go up on those days
like i have movie reviews that i did
that i put up on those days because i
feel bad
i was like well every day
i have to put something up it's gonna be
all right i don't know why i feel like
that
ah i don't know it's it's my thing it's
i always have to be like making
something or producing something or i
feel like useless i don't know what it
is
it's a sickness
i get it gotta be it is i'm messaging
people messaging people seeing if they
got a place to go
yeah just yeah don't like announce it no
i'm not i'm going on public just doing
a-listers first you're doing a-listers
first yeah yeah i'm doing a those just
first
like people we actually yeah we actually
know that well people that have actually
been to our house before people i
actually trust won't [ __ ] steal from
my [ __ ] house
all right
all right so where was i okay um what
was i talking about oh okay so we were
talking about
this uh hotel in deadwood
so
cesco's still lurking around there
staring at people not doing their [ __ ]
what
why are you out there smoking like get
to work that kind of thing
um also
reported on multiple occasions a bunch
of guests staying in the hotel have said
that they've heard their name called by
a male voice when nobody is around
creepy
um or somebody's tapping them on the
shoulder again creepy
some people have reported footsteps in
the hallways or whistling and there's
nobody there
uh there's also uh some kind of [ __ ]
like particularly on the second and
third floor rooms
many people who've stayed at the hotel
reporting taking pictures and having
like weird anomalies in them i'm
guessing like orbs or weird
you know smudges or whatever
um
alarm clocks going off when they're not
plugged in
uh tvs going off and on changing
channels things like that by themselves
uh people have seen apparitions
like sort of
nebulous figures in the rooms and in the
hallways
and uh there is supposedly in this hotel
even an anti-clock that is broken
that sometimes will just uh kind of
chime and go off even though it
supposedly doesn't work anymore now this
particular hotel the bullock hotel
has uh been on unsolved mysteries
actually
i don't know what season that was but
this was one that was on there
um so yeah so basically uh one of the
pretty much one of the most famous
haunted places in deadwood
um and as far as i know
still open uh and it has a casino if
you're into that
uh you can get married there if you're
into that all kind of stuff
uh also has a ghost tour because of
course it does
i mean why not
why not cash in on that dj maniac says
i'm an a-lister but i'm and with nowhere
to go but i'm up in new york
up here i'd have you up here no problem
but fly down here can you yeah if you
could fly
but he could fly here that means he
could buy his own [ __ ]
thanksgiving dinner though see that's
the thing yeah but the thing about it is
that thanksgiving dinner is always
better when somebody had to log that
flight real quick fly up here somebody
else maybe yeah yeah and the thing about
it is like thanksgiving i kind of like
thanksgiving in the us is
the most heavily traveled yeah
day of the year like the time about yeah
well even now yeah
everybody's trying to get home to their
families because this is kind of like
even more than christmas i think right
because most people are kind of like
well i'll have thanksgiving with you
guys and then i'm gonna have christmas
with my own family or the other side of
family or whatever so i do kind of feel
like
thanksgiving is kind of a big deal for
travel
and i've heard
i don't i'm i i never was in a position
where i had to travel like at flying or
anything on thanksgiving but i've heard
it as a [ __ ] nightmare yeah
as i said sometimes i'll go to see my
mom
let's go down there yeah you and elsa
come down here yeah come on
if you can make it on time i got the
[ __ ] food
uh the closest airport would have been
uh sanford international airport that's
the easiest one you want to fly into
if you can get a crazy ass flight be
here by tomorrow or probably around i
don't know tj made x's i can't even
afford a bus ticket i know that feeling
[Laughter]
but if you could sometimes you can get a
flight down here
for like 100 bucks
well the thing about it as i said yes we
have orlando international but
the airport that's closer to us actually
is sanford international smaller
international and it's much smaller yeah
and sometimes you can fly from like a
little more obscure airport a little
more out of the way airport to this one
and it's way way cheaper and it's much
much easier because orlando
international and it's not like the
worst airport i've been to the worst
airport i've been to i think was atlanta
or gatwick uh which are like five
[ __ ]
you know terminals and it's just a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] what's funny about sanford
is that's where all the rich people fly
in
well sanford is like it's one
it's one terminal it's one terminal and
it's it's tiny and i think it was built
to serve [ __ ] uh downtown stanford
but sanford sanford where markham woods
stanford where all the rich people yet
and that's what it was meant to serve
it's easy and weird obscure
[ __ ] airliners [ __ ] coming like
i've never heard of this airline i flew
one of them
when i when my dad had the [ __ ]
operation i flew out of that
that one to another it's kind of obscure
well
i flew it flew into
um new orleans [ __ ] international
airport
and uh i was on i was on a damn
airplane i never even [ __ ] heard of i
couldn't even remember it and i got
[ __ ] great service
on it it was great
they had cute
cute stewardesses and everything giving
me
a week we don't know how to make a
mojito if
you had to tell the flight attendants
how to make a mojito yeah i said do you
have a mojito
uh no i don't know we don't know what
the [ __ ] is that
yeah i told her no we don't have that
are you from florida we haven't yeah
they want to hear all about florida and
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's just cool it's
cool but it was a little bitty jet
yeah and it was only um
it was 130 each way
was it even that much i thought i
thought it was cheaper than that 70.
yeah i thought it was under a hundred
dollars yeah it was ridiculous and i was
like and the and you went the same day
because you got the phone call the same
[ __ ] day from your dad
and you're like i'm going yeah and you
said get me a flight today yeah from
stanford i feel like i was cheating like
i had found some kind of cheat code
and it was a cheap [ __ ] flight on a
great little bitty [ __ ] jet
the jet only had like
40 people on it
it was it was it was just a little bitty
jet
you know i don't know what kind of jet
it was
little little two engine jet little two
engines underneath well to be honest
even back in the 90s and the early 2000s
um
when i was like my ex-husband's
relatives who were british or welsh
um when they wanted to come to florida
for vacation
most of them would fly they're like no
it's too expensive to fly at a gatwick
or heat like heathrow is the main london
airport gatwick is
the
slightly lesser but still kind of
expensive london airport because
london's so big it has two big massive
airports
so a lot of them will fly out of
manchester
which is not that much farther and then
they'll fly to like a smaller airport so
uh his relatives actually flew from
manchester to sanford
um and it was super cheap yeah they were
very excited about that she was cheap
and then i mean they had to take a bus
like from sanford to orlando but it's
not that far yeah it was cheap
flying to new orleans and back
and the jet was little and it was like
flying first class and it and it didn't
have many people on the jet
it wasn't even like a [ __ ] big name i
couldn't tell you what it was what it
the airplane was red
as i remember the airplane was red
and um good food and uh everybody's
[ __ ] drinking on the plane and
talking it didn't feel like a normal
commute it didn't really feel like a
normal uh like flying delta or [ __ ]
pan am where it's like big jet
everybody's in there's like a big bus
you know it didn't feel like that felt
like i was on damn private jet a big bus
and everybody's like clipping their
toenails behind you and [ __ ] like that
yeah everybody's talking yeah yeah yeah
it was fun it's like like you're on a
private jet [ __ ] touring around
[ __ ]
with the rock stars and [ __ ]
had a great time
the only time i've been on a really
small plane like that was when i flew
from i flew from daytona
to denver yeah and then i flew from
denver to santa fe and the flight from
denver to santa fe is like a tiny little
eight person or twelve person airplane
yeah um
and that was weirdly
you would think that being in a littler
plane like that me being really afraid
to fly do you think that'd be worse
but for some reason it was better yeah i
don't really know why let me tell you
guys something you guys don't may not
know this millionaires and billionaires
like [ __ ] super rich people that are
just known
they fly all over and they fly into the
in and out of these little tiny almost
private
airstrips
and they don't have passports
ain't that some [ __ ] they don't go
through customs
well they don't have to do [ __ ] the rest
of us
nope they're gonna do it like plebes
they're gonna go through customers get
away with passports
and that's like money and get away they
almost have damn diplomatic immunity and
yes they [ __ ] bring drugs in doing
that [ __ ]
oh epstein's island and [ __ ] [ __ ] had
big barrels of [ __ ]
because he was involved with a drug
company and they had big barrels of
[ __ ] mysterious [ __ ]
sarms and weird
different versions of cocaine and stuff
like that and
think we're transporting that all around
they're all with all their little
friends
because they don't have to go through
customs
and it's not just him they're all like
that
imagine that no passports
well yeah like i said the the rich are a
different species pretty much they can
just do it and do whatever they want
yeah i can't imagine what that must be
like i'm gonna have to get into that
[ __ ]
yeah good luck with that
good luck with that
i have a dollar yeah
that's what i'd be up there saying i'm
gonna get involved in that [ __ ]
oh my god
rebecca dunn says i was mortified at how
small the jacksonville north carolina
airport was flew from melbourne florida
yeah i've never been to that airport but
small airports are better you'd have to
wait in all those lines yeah i mean yeah
honestly the sanford airport to me seems
like a really good size because it still
has international flights or at least
flights that connect to international
flights
um
but it's manageable still
yeah you know it'd be crowded and it's
nice i mean even the orlando airport
which i think is only three terminals
yeah is
a nightmare i hate packed driving to the
orlando airport
the traffic around it is a [ __ ]
nightmare i hate it i hate it picking
people up is a nightmare i hate it
i hate that
and that's not even like i said it's not
even the worst or most crowded airport
i've ever been to
relatively compared to atlanta or london
it's not that crowded or new york
because i've been at jfk airport many
times it's not that crowded relatively
but it's still like the traffic around
it is
horrifying
and it's just i don't know it's just a
big pain sanford you show up you [ __ ]
get your ticket you walk in here's my
bag take my bag thank you i'm gonna get
where's the plane okay i'll be right on
you're on the plane let's fly it's just
that [ __ ] well in picking somebody up
yeah
you don't have to like when you pick
somebody up from orlando yeah you can't
just wait you have to like drive around
and around and around they're like no
you can't park here you have to keep
driving around and it's like and the the
road that you have to drive around on is
like super treacherous yeah and it's a
bunch of
orlando is like a big tourist
destination so it's a bunch of
[ __ ] that have no idea where
they're going yeah um and are from other
parts of the world where they don't know
how to drive or don't know how to or
don't care to drive or don't care about
driving
so it's like it's really hair-raising
like going there but they they are very
very
because we've had to like pick people up
from this airport a bunch of times and
you they really will not let you which
you try to get away with it like you
pull over in the cab and you're just
like oh look there's the person there's
the person they're like yeah we we don't
we see that yeah that's you're not we're
not falling for that get out
100 tom i don't know what you're talking
about you got to give me some uh
you have to give me some context baby
100 tom i don't know
it's a hundred percent 100 time yeah
i don't know what she's talking about
100 times she's agreeing with something
i said but i don't know what she's
agreeing with yeah you say so much stuff
i said so much it's really hard to like
yeah
it's really hard to determine what we're
agreeing with what we're not agreeing
with
but uh yeah so let me can i talk about
another question all right
now
this is a good one too because i like
this one because it's gruesome okay so
uh so we're talking about this one this
is uh the legend of el nuerto
a what el muerto muerto the dead guy
or the headless horseman okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah mexican's just gonna so
the dead guy the dead guy
well he's dead that's for sure
so yeah so this happened in the 1800s in
texas this is texas
uh so basically okay so what happened
uh this is kind of like the whole
context behind the situation
so the united states says
the rio grande
is the border between u.s and mexico
uh mexican government says no
actually the border is the nueces river
that's the border
so while they were disputing where the
border was between where those two
rivers was was this huge
sort of lawless area that was kind of
known as sort of like a no man's land
type of situation and there was like a
lot of outlaw lawlessness activity going
on there
now uh so this was one of the things
that led up to the uh war with mexico in
1846
uh which established the rio grande as
the official border
but
uh between that happening there was like
30 years of kind of like some
in between [ __ ] where the border was
kind of still disputed so that chunk of
land between those two rivers was still
kind of essentially like a lawless area
now so the thing about it so you have
the texas rangers
uh who were kind of out there patrolling
this area
two of whom were these dudes named creed
taylor and will
the dude with the fabulous name william
alexander anderson bigfoot wallace who
i'm just going to call bigfoot from now
on because that's an awesome nickname
uh so
what ends up happening
1850
there's a dude who's like a kind of like
a criminal type
guy he's known as vidal
and he's a cattle rustler
and he's been doing this [ __ ] all over
south texas
and because he's been doing all this
cattle wrestling which as we mentioned
earlier i think we've talked about horse
thievery but cattle wrestling also very
serious crime uh so he was doing that
and uh he was kind of like flaunting it
i guess so he had a very high uh price
on his head
so if you uh brought him in
dead or alive
there was a big reward
now what ended up happening was that in
the summer of 1850
there was a raid by the comanches
and a lot of the dudes that were
supposed to be kind of like guarding
this lawless area kind of went off to
fight the comanches right
so vidal says to himself well [ __ ] um
you know all the law enforcement's gone
so i'm gonna take advantage of this [ __ ]
right here and i'm just gonna like run
willy-nilly all over this area so that's
kind of what he was doing
now uh so vidal he had three of his uh
buddies
his little henchmen
so they started uh you know doing their
[ __ ] getting a bunch of horses
cattle [ __ ] like that
uh stealing a bunch of stuff and kind of
heading toward uh mexico while most of
the law enforcement was elsewhere
occupied
however uh among the horses that vidal
and his buddies stole
uh were a bunch of mustangs that
actually belong to one of the texas
rangers
of this story creed taylor
um now it so happened that creed taylor
although he would normally have gone
along to kind of defend the territory up
north against the comanches did not go
on this occasion for whatever reason
uh so basically what he did
uh was
he decided
okay i've had enough of this
[ __ ] stealing my [ __ ]
horses
and so he gets his buddy bigfoot
that's because well that was his
nickname yeah bigfoot wallin
i don't know why they called him that
because he was like had big feet or he
was really hairy i don't really know
uh so
him and bigfoot and this other dude like
a rancher named flores they said we're
gonna go like root this dude out
so
they uh basically trail vidal and his
three buddies
now they the three of them they tracked
them all through the you know wilds or
the planes or whatever
they found the outlaws in the camp
and then they decided to go the easy
route i guess they waited all the
[ __ ] were asleep and then they
attacked which yeah that's probably the
smartest that's what you do that's the
smart city does the same thing yeah well
you know
well you don't want problems no you know
no when they're unaware that's when you
it's like you you [ __ ] gotta sleep
sometime we're just gonna like wait till
you fall asleep so that's what they did
they wait till they fell asleep and then
they jump in and they just start like
killing all of them
so uh so they jumped in they killed all
of them
but what they did they said okay well
killing them
that's not sufficient we also need to
send a [ __ ] message okay yeah so what
they did
was they took um
they took vidal
and they who was the leader of the horse
rustling and cattle wrestling gang
they cut his head off
and then they took his headless body
and they like tied it into the saddle
on the back of a wild mustang
so like they tied his hands to the
saddle and then they kind of wanted to
help hold him up right so they tied them
all up right also
they kind of like took his head
and they put a sombrero on it just to be
funny i guess
and they kind of like also tied that to
the saddle so it kind of like hang like
it's swaying back and forth like when
the horse ran yeah so they did that
and then they just let the horse loose
chin horses
let it run around and like let it
be like let this be a lesson to you this
is what will happen
now what ended up happening was that
over the subsequent
days or weeks or whatever
uh obviously many people saw this horse
with a headless dude sitting on it and
kind of flipped out yeah as you would
um so they would like shoot at it or
like shoot arrows at it or whatever the
poor horse yeah that's what yeah
you know the horse lives well so it's
it's fine um you know because i was kind
of worried about that too i was like
wait what happened to this but this poor
horse didn't ask to be involved in this
[ __ ] yeah horses do not like dead
things yeah and and you would think so
so yeah so
so this horse is going around with his
[ __ ] headless body sitting on it
and uh so
what ended up happening was that because
so many people saw it and didn't really
know what the [ __ ] it was and like shot
at it and stuff so this legend starts to
grow up about a headless horseman type
character which they started calling
like el muerto now eventually
they did um you know and it became a
kind of thing where it's like oh if you
see it you know it became kind of like a
death portent at some point it's like oh
man some bad shit's gonna happen because
we saw old el muerte or whatever
now they did actually end up uh catching
the horse
at a watering hole
uh you know in texas
and they did find
this [ __ ] desiccated ass headless
corpse on the back of it uh and it had a
bunch of bullet holes and arrows to get
out of it and [ __ ] like that
so they cut it off of the horse poor
horse poor's like thank you
and they buried it in some unmarked
grave somewhere and they let the horse
freak so it was a wild mustang
so uh but because that had been such a
i guess such a memorable image
uh the legend lived on that there was
this like ghostly
headless horseman essentially character
that
you know when you saw it that was like a
portent of like bad fortune you know
what i mean but it was actually
supposedly based on a real thing because
some dudes were like yeah we're gonna
strap a headless dude to a horse and let
it run around and nobody like [ __ ]
shot at it and stuff apparently that
really did happen but that's where that
legend came from
uh so
but yeah so even nowadays like people
have seen like
or say they've seen like a ghostly one
like a headless
horseman essentially like running around
i think there was a there was a report
of it in 1917
a couple that were going out to san
diego they said that they saw
uh a horse like a ghostly horse with a
headless uh dude on it so that's kind of
another thing too
all right so
let's talk about
uh tombstone
arizona
probably one of the most famous towns of
the old west
it's funny i was like watching something
about the history of tombstone
the reason that it's called tombstone
because i always wondered about this
was because the guy who founded it
when he was gonna go out i don't think
he was going out to found a town
necessarily but he was going out to
i can't remember mine for gold or mine
for silver some
and all his friends told him it's like
and he said oh i'm going to this area
and they were like well
it's your funeral or it's your tombstone
and
when he went out there he actually found
like this huge vein of silver or
whatever and he made all this money and
ended up founding a town and just to
[ __ ] with them he called it tombstone
because he's like you guys said that
this would be my tombstone and now i'm
rich so [ __ ] you so it was that kind of
situation i don't know if that's true
but that's what i heard
so uh yeah so the probably the most uh
famous thing that happened in tombstone
probably like the okay corral obviously
which we'll get into in a minute
but what ended up happening so like i
said there's so many [ __ ] ghost
stories from tombstone and i think these
are like the last ones i'm going to
cover because i'm probably getting too
drunk to talk about it at this point
yeah
i'm going to catch up with cooking and
stuff too i'm going to have to like prep
for um
green bean casserole if you all know
what i'm talking about it's the green
beans with the [ __ ] camel soup
mushroom with the campbell mushroom soup
cream of mushroom soup and the [ __ ]
fried onions on top i'm gonna do that
okay talk for a second
i'm gonna make brazilian cream style
corn
okay
and uh see what else i gotta make for
tomorrow
i think that's it now i gotta bake the
turkey gotta do two different kinds of
gravy's i'm gonna do a regular yellow
turkey gravy and then everything that's
going to come out of my stock pot
because my stock is what it's going to
put and then the
the green gravy
has got the giblets and the damn
celery and onions out of the damn
stockpot i make a gravy out of that too
so that's kind of like my i don't know
that's just how i do it because i can't
bring myself to throw that stock away
you know
and
i like those giblets i don't like all
the damn liver i like a little bit but i
don't like a lot of it
i only use about half of it well liver
is a very distinctive flavor i only use
a little bit of it it's good and very
very small doses
but
not so much but i like that chewy
giblets and i like the [ __ ]
um
neck meat i think there's a heart in
there dang goodbye
no maybe not
i thought there was yeah it might be i
got away because i thought you talked
about i just have all that [ __ ] thawing
right now it's in water it's gone i'll
go back and look at it again came out of
that bag
yeah
all right
all right here that'll go in there too
okay so let's talk about a couple of the
ghosts in tombstone and then we'll wrap
this up yeah because
it's getting late we're getting drunk
and we got food to cook so let's talk
about tombstone okay
so like i said whole bunch of ghost
stories from [ __ ] tombstone man yeah
okay corral
yeah that too
and honestly like go buzzfeed unsolved
they did a whole like tombstone episode
so they did a whole okay corral thing
they did a whole bunch of [ __ ] and it
was like funny
earlier the best show on the okay corral
is on star trek the original series
where kirk and mccoy and spock all get i
remember that trapped in the milk milk
melton and [ __ ] the milk cots the
male cop [ __ ]
simulation where they're going to be
judged based upon the okay chorale yeah
that was that was the best one
the actual okay corral actually looking
not a lot of dudes got killed um and uh
both sides were bad include the sheriff
was kind of [ __ ] well i kind of feel
like
i mean if you go there now obviously
it's a it's a tourist uh destination
nowadays and they have
figures of all the people
in the exact positions that they were
supposedly in when the gunfight took
place right
now
from my understanding
i kind of feel like maybe
this was
the law enforcement being a little
overzealous
just because you had a badge didn't mean
that you were really the good that's
what i'm saying it's just another gang
because i mean yeah the other ones were
a gang and they were and a couple of
them were armed but a lot of but a
couple of them weren't they were
basically fighting over women
that's really when you get down to it
they were kind of fighting over women
the [ __ ]
the law wanted the other guys out
a lot of it had to do with the saloons
and the women in the area if you ask me
they didn't like they apparently this is
how it's supposed to go they they
apparently didn't like
that the gang came in and some of them
were armed like i said not all of them
were so they were basically like because
they did have a law at that time back
then
that yeah you're supposed to check your
weapons you weren't real yeah you
weren't really supposed to be walking
around with like guns i know because i
kind of feel like people see westerns
and they think everybody's just walking
around with guns in their hips all the
time not no that was actually not that
was against the law and that was kind of
one of the things that the sheriffs were
like they thought that the gang was
coming in they're trying to cause
trouble
because a couple of them were armed like
i said not all of them were but a couple
of them did have
guns so alternate versions of the story
involve women though that there was
always a backstory between the two there
might have been yeah that they were
competing for the same group of women
at the local bar at the local
i don't want to call it the women
weren't allowed in saloons that's
something you only see in tv but they
had little cat houses and parlors and
[ __ ]
and that that particular gang was
evidently kind of popular with the women
and they weren't considered to be
[ __ ]
legitimate dudes they were kind of
borderline kind of criminals
uh and
the law didn't want didn't want him in
there but those dudes were bad too it
was
yeah it was kind of like most likely it
was women were involved in it that's it
always gets back to that
money and women
is is we're the cause for everything
well in the old west that had a lot to
do with things money women and really
money always had to do excuse me
booze and women
that was a big thing and money
okay money represented booze and women
to these guys
all right which is
the same thing yeah so really it all
kind of goes back down to [ __ ] women
not a lot of pleasures back then so
russia kind of had to take david compete
for women and that's what i think the
okay chorale was mostly what was about
really women
keeping those dudes out they were
probably too hot they're probably hot it
might have been
okay
i don't know how much of that guys you
you lost it
it boils down to women uh if you ask me
probably it's what it was they were
probably cuter than the law the law had
to get get rid of them the women were
too much attention for the women
it's always something [ __ ] dumb like
that um
yeah they might have been shifty but
shifty men are attract women like guys
that are like that you know just well
up to a point up to a certain point so
it was but it was probably something
like that most likely
um
[Laughter]
[ __ ] old west the the west the old
west was a trip you know they were they
were dumb and
competed for women a lot and that's just
what i think it was well women were um
an uncommon commodity i guess there
weren't enough women to go around no no
and you know you're the you're the law
and this is your town and you trying to
[ __ ] dominate and you're [ __ ]
these women all belong to you and these
new dudes come in and
they're hotter than you and you're just
gonna have to put your foot down that's
probably what more to do than anything
yeah you couldn't carry a gun into town
but dudes did it anyway and they also
had permits for it
if the locals would allow you know if
the local
sheriff said yeah you could carry a gun
then you could um you probably had to
pay maybe or it was just something you
signed on paper or just some kind of
agreement
um but then
another thing was is that
they didn't want you openly carrying
lever action carbines or
a [ __ ] uh break breech
double-barreled shotguns and they didn't
want you
carrying
[ __ ] sick shooters on your [ __ ]
hips openly you had to check that in to
check those into the [ __ ] sheriff's
office on your way in
but they were kinda lenient about vest
pocket pistols
which were
two barrel derringers they knew
everybody was carrying them some of them
were carrying single shot pistols in
their boots
you weren't supposed to be doing that
but sometimes they let it slide
it's kind of like they didn't see they
were like well that's a defensive weapon
that's just in case somebody you know
what i mean
now if you shout somebody unjustly
they'd hang you
but the old west what they consider to
be self-defense was [ __ ] um pretty
lenient
if somebody was it said something
sideways and [ __ ] made a move towards
you
you could [ __ ] blow them away
so it kept them all
polite
this is a dueling society i totally
believe in dueling dueling would prevent
a lot of [ __ ]
but if you're gonna duel
there has to be a public challenge and
there's got to be lawyers involved and
they're placed at a time to do the duel
and
peop people have to say yeah this duel
is going to happen and well everyone has
to agree to it and everyone has to agree
to the terms right and you can use the
duel to call [ __ ] on a [ __ ]
okay well you you you don't accept a
challenge then you're a liar or you're a
coward you shouldn't have said what you
said take it back that type of deal i
totally believe in that and some people
be like well what are you talking
dueling was never
adjudicated it was never really
adjudicated out of the american system
it really should be there
it was just over time people said nah
we're not gonna do that
it legally should be there
if the state
can legally wage war against another
state
and draft men to fight that war for them
what gives the state the right
to deny a man his own
right to declare war against another
individual it's it totally
unconstitutional well like i said if you
had um if there were parameters in place
where everyone consented it's like yeah
we're all going to sign this thing that
these are the conditions
right yeah i don't have a problem with
that right
and that was stop as long as everybody
is everybody's consenting
everybody knows what's going to happen
it would act as a pressure valve and
then anybody who kills somebody else
outside of a duel you can now label him
an assassin
okay which is that's that's a big
difference
okay if you're a [ __ ] assassin then
oh man that's the lowest of the low
because if you want to kill a dude
challenge him to the [ __ ] duel yeah
that's that would be like saying you
don't have any honor you don't have any
[ __ ] honor right right yeah
and if he says no then that's because
he's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] he's a punk
and he's a hoe
oh man all of those things all of them
together it was back to the okay corral
which was kind of like a duel in a way
well we're talking about tombstone in
general yeah i'll get to the okay ground
okay i'm just talking about like
generally ghosts that have seen around
tombstone then we'll get to okay corral
as much right
so one of the ghosts that is supposedly
supposed to haunt tombstone
is this dude named marshall fred white
now in
1880 this dude was actually accidentally
this is kind of shitty he was
accidentally shot by a guy named curly
bill brochus curly bill brochus he was
the head of the cowboy gang now what
ended up happening was that marshall
fred white apparently
was kind of like he was the first
marshal of tombstone
and
he was kind of like um
even though he was a law man he was kind
of respected by gang like you know the
clanton gang was all kind of like all
right he's all right
um and he had actually arrested some uh
other members of the gang and nobody had
really given him trouble about it
um
but what happened though
was that this dude who was
one of the gang leaders the cowboy
faction leader curly bill
they decided
uh you know him and his buddies they're
gonna come in town and just for shits
and giggles they're gonna shoot up the
place which
you know not not really an ideal
situation so they're gonna come in and
shoot up the place
so the marshall comes in
tries to take his gun away because he's
like dude what the [ __ ] are you even
doing
um at which point he gets shot
accidentally and it hits him
right in the groin every man watching
this is now like oh yeah hit right i
don't know if it was a testicle or just
in the [ __ ] i don't know there's a
lot of places that could have gone
that's what i'm saying i just do groin
is a big area what is it did he shoot
him in the dick was it a testicle i
don't really know
now they thought that
he'd been shot in the groin so like well
he'll probably recover however he did
not he died two days later
he was like if i don't have my groin i
can't live anymore and he just gave up
the ghost i guess i'm just i'm making
that up
so uh apparently that dude is still
supposed to haunt the place where he got
shot she's like you shot my dick
that you shot my dick ghost sorry dude
that's a shitty way to go but uh yeah so
he's supposed to haunt there there's
another uh ghost that is supposed to be
oh it's going red again god damn it
we've had a lot of trouble in this [ __ ]
tonight
it's like it's not
like you know it's not turning off all
the way but it just seems like it's
really intermittent yeah
you know like it's have a problem yeah
it's like it's making me really it's
stressing me
out danny rolling ghost faces tombstone
frozen pizzas put that place on the map
those are pretty good actually well it's
got quite a name so it's been remembered
and some [ __ ] happened there but
i mean well um they made that movie too
well they made more than one movie but
there was that one movie called
tombstone that had val kilmer in that
[ __ ] yeah i kind of feel like val
cameron there's been a lot of different
spins on the okay corral incident
well it's because i never know i mean so
many people were involved
that
no one's entirely sure what because
everybody kind of has a different story
about it and everyone over time has had
that has had their own interpretation
even the people that were there
don't agree on what exactly happened or
why
well and as time goes on you're just
like man why why did we even start
shooting people man i don't remember i
think it's about women
isn't it always yeah i think it was you
dudes shooting each other over girls i
think it was it was it was jealousy i
think
it might have been yeah like you said
that have been really funny little okay
corral thing people talk about it 100
something years later
that it was just kind of like well we
don't like these dudes came in town that
are kind of like
bad boys and they're like hotter than us
yeah i think that's probably where we're
gonna we're gonna like go you can't come
in this town we're gonna clamp down on
that you gotta get out of this town
that's probably what it was
that's what made the most sense to me
because
if not then these shootouts would have
happened all the time everywhere
uh because a lot of the dudes were doing
what
that situation was over this was a
personal season
if you asked me it wasn't just uh
run-of-the-mill law enforcement yeah
it was well they seemed to have a
personal beef yeah it was personal yeah
because as i mentioned they were kind of
like hey like one of you guys is
carrying i think two of the gang had
guns but the rest of them didn't
so the fact that they called them out on
it when like you said other people were
probably carrying you got away with it
they're like they were just looking for
some [ __ ] yeah and they kind of came in
and announced apparently the gang is
just kind of like hanging out in this
lot and they weren't really doing
anything yeah and the law enforcement
kind of comes over and it's like hey you
guys looking for a fight yeah and there
and i think the first quote of one of
them said was like hey we don't yeah
that's how i remember we're not looking
for we're not looking for a fight it's
fine we're just like hanging out i don't
remember all the details just that once
i studied it years ago and i came away
with the opinion is that what it was is
that
the these bad boys blew into town that
were hotter than the cops and the cops
weren't standing for it and they were of
all about the same age
okay the cops weren't taking it they
were really not yo you all don't need to
be around here
which the only reason why dudes would do
that is because they don't want women
that they're running or gunning for they
don't want them to see these dudes
that's what it is that's what we will
look shitty by comparison they're like
[ __ ] it's something like that
that's hilarious yeah that's hilarious
you can't come into my town i don't want
these women seeing you looking all foxy
like that
that's probably what it is
don't be high-minded it's going to be
something dumb
dumb and real understandable if you've
seen them it probably makes it
well why it's funny to me is that i kind
of really well
why that's funny to me is because i kind
of feel like a lot of dudes
have a perception that women are like
that there's like oh we don't want like
hotter girls than us like around
but
yeah in my experience it's funny that
that dudes kind of [ __ ] on women for
being that way i'm like no dudes are
totally like that men are projecting
that yeah exactly that's why that's
funny to me because it's totally
projection yeah that's totally
projection that's what i think is like
i'm not saying that like women aren't
like yeah i don't want to like stand
next to a hotter girl because that does
happen but you know you don't want to
like stand next to somebody that's going
to make you look like a sack of [ __ ] in
comparison but and the law men and the
big players of that town doc holliday
was one of them they were running game
on that town they were the [ __ ] kings
the roost
they had all the tension of all the
hotties they weren't going to let these
dudes come in there
all right that's what it would do it's
like ooh like i said they're bad boys
yeah that's what it was i i think that's
what it was because if you guys don't
dog holiday doc holiday they have more
teeth than us dog holiday was a [ __ ]
player okay he was a player and and his
main girlfriend worked in one of those
brothels she was a star
and
they didn't want them [ __ ] cuties
coming in here [ __ ]
doing business with the [ __ ] horn in
all yeah they don't want that
they didn't want it nobody wants that's
my that was my take on it back then
you're gonna refresh my memory as the
story unfolds i mean that sounds about
right there that's how i remember that's
i was going yeah that's probably what it
was
because you got to read in between the
lines this is man business because why
did they pick on those dudes
particularly exactly it didn't have
anything to do with crime or anything
like that it was they want them hot
[ __ ] coming in there
[Laughter]
yeah and they weren't looking for
trouble
some of them wanted to leave
and other ones were like oh no no they
shouldn't be kicking us out we hadn't
done anything wrong and you know that's
that's what it was that's kind of the
perception that i had because i kind of
feel like they came into town
and they were just not doing i mean they
were just hanging out they weren't doing
anything they're just like standing
around they probably didn't know why the
law was picking on them because they
probably well that was like i said i
kind of feel like that's kind of the
main quote the cops can't kind of came
and we're like oh you guys are looking
for a fight they're like nah bro we're
just like hanging out we're not doing
anything yeah what he really should what
he really meant y'all in here looking
for [ __ ] aren't you yeah and
yeah i guess so because you can't not my
town
that's what the reason those are all
ours yeah yeah all the [ __ ] exactly all
the [ __ ] is belong to us all the best
[ __ ] we're already hitting it y'all
can't come in here because the second
and third rail [ __ ] we don't know we
know the second third rate [ __ ] you're
not gonna be [ __ ] interested in and
you're definitely not getting ours
that's probably what it was
that sounds bad my man detector detects
that's what the situation was
you act like i'm high-minded when it
comes to dudes i'm like no what it's
dudes i just assume that it's the
dumbest [ __ ] possible yeah
i'm not gonna tell it it usually is
they're not gonna tell it in this way
they'll justify it later exactly like
they have some kind of smart i'm like
nah they were dangerous guys that's not
why they were no good and they were not
good
i see right through that [ __ ]
that's not probably not what it was
y'all think you're being like all like
subterfuge and stuff it's like it's not
working that's not working but uh dandy
rolling ghost face says known by the
ladies as [ __ ] holiday
[ __ ] holiday was [ __ ] when he when
he would roll up into the saloon and
play [ __ ] uh play cards and [ __ ] uh
he was always known to carry a big old
jar glass juice believe in you it's bad
it's coming back
yeah we're having all as soon as we
start talking about anything racy
[ __ ] they want to shut us down i'm
going to the restroom go ahead and read
it well like i said i was talking about
ghosts and random candy and [ __ ] like
that and it shut down so it doesn't have
anything to do with anything i know you
like to like make patterns out of [ __ ]
but
uh yeah elsa said i just pictured like
cowboy chicken chippendales dance
oh my god has somebody please please
tell me that somebody's made a porn
parody
of the okay corral situation whereas
like
[ __ ] clinton gang's coming in like
all like [ __ ] naked
little raw head chaps on [ __ ] oh my god
that'd be so [ __ ] funny
uh tom and jenny have you seen a wide
earp i haven't i don't think i've seen
it i saw tombstone which is actually
really good but i don't think i've seen
wyatt earp actually
um cause i'm not i'm not super into
westerns i like some but
um you know it's not usually a genre i
seek out
uh yeah hugo says you're back yeah sorry
we we keep like cutting out i don't know
what the [ __ ] deal is
i don't know the [ __ ] our internet is
drunk
as drunk as i am
uh yeah so where was i yeah dude got
shot in the groin that that would blow
and then died two days later and still
haunts the [ __ ] which i would too to be
fair
if i was shot in the groin
and then died from it uh so there's
another ghost that people have seen in
tombstone so apparently there's this
dude and he has this big
like black frock coat
and he's been seen on a bunch of
occasions like kind of crossing the road
and he's been seen in the uh right near
the area where virgil earp
brother
was ambushed and shot in the arm because
i don't know if you guys know but after
the ok corral situation happened
most of the law enforcement dudes uh
involved in that shootout ended up
getting
essentially assassinated later on
uh you know so there was that
so yeah virgil erp got an ambush and
shot in the air but we've seen this
ghost in this same location where that
happened so maybe people are thinking
this ghost is actually virgil or maybe
ah is it going red again
yeah it went it stopped for a bit but
it's coming back
this is it's starting to make me
give me more alcohol i'm getting mad
yeah give me more alcohol i'll get you
more alcohol okay
i need more alcohol well this is like
blinking it's like get it's blinking all
the [ __ ]
lights at me it's making me angry it's
making me angry
why why are you doing this i don't know
it's back it's green okay but it went
red again a second ago too
i don't know man what the [ __ ] we don't
it's not we don't live in the [ __ ] we
don't live in [ __ ] antarctica what
the [ __ ] is going on no man jesus christ
i just i don't know i get really annoyed
when [ __ ] doesn't like fights it's 21st
[ __ ] century goddammit
i don't understand why it's not working
all right
so let's okay so another ghost that
people have reported that there is a a
woman in a long white dress
walking around the streets of tombstone
now nobody knows oh thank you nobody
knows exactly who this woman is
uh some people think that she is the
mother of a kid
who died of yellow fever in the 1880s as
a lot of people did
um
some people thought that she was maybe a
madam of a brothel who was hanged for
whatever reason
and uh is kind of like walking around
looking for the people that hanged her
so she can [ __ ] him up in her ghostly
way
nobody knows
now uh much like we mentioned earlier
every single [ __ ] town in the old
west god damn it
don't you go red again
come on okay
every single [ __ ] town in the old
west has burned down at least once
uh tombstone
had two of the two of these things it's
red yep yep
the [ __ ] is wrong with this [ __ ]
i don't know what it's making me angry
it's making me angry
what's wrong with this [ __ ]
now it's back to green
okay that's
okay it's good
it's doing this thing
it's doing that thing that it's doing
yeah
i mean like i'm almost done i'm just you
know